[Music]
hold on
I talk can't you hear the thing when
your lights off can't talk heavy with a
light Joe my wind might lose or my draw
ERS
in the ring God don't send the contract
off knock his contacts out you will feel
mice trying to take a Viper ain't no
competition in the ring of Cypher cause
I'm spitting
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
y'all can hear me clear
let me get some ones in the chat if you
can hear me clear let me get some ones
in the chat if you can hear me clear
what's going on
East Texas Alex Bob's Adventure coin I
ain't lost yourself King gangoon what's
good baby
hi Linden Master welcome to the world
wise what's good baby
all right
welcome to the first combat talk 2023
it's crazy right now my wife's sitting
down here with us
it's gonna be a good day you heard
um yeah you know tank fighting and we
got a Dominican fighting so you know for
a fact she gonna be outside stand up
Dominican Republic all right boo-boo's
fighting right now
I'm not gonna lie uh this is booboo's
first fight with uh the PVC actually
it's really with showtime and he wants
to do a deal with the PPC I knew boo-boo
was going to come out with a lackluster
uh type of fight he started off very
heavy bubu's a messy fighter right
um he's very sloppy very unorthodox uh
very clumsy in in his approach uh he's
not very pleasing to the eye to watch
but he does have good attributes
and I'm talking about uh Demetrius
Andrade so if anybody know him talk
about Demetrius Andrade so right now in
the card uh Demetrius Andrade is pulling
up the the the rear end of the card this
is probably one of the best cards that
we're gonna get in a long time because
uh you have a booboo uh making this
fight uh at Super middleweight uh 168 so
you know he's trying to Target David
benavidez and from what I'm seeing right
now if he's fighting David benavidez
like this David Benavides is going to
eat this man alive he's talking about
Charlo I don't even know why he's even
mentioning charlo's name and he's out
here struggling with a dude named
Nicholson not even something that you
want to see not at all not going to
happen but also we got Speedy rashidi on
this card so he's fighting next and
that's Villa versus Ellis Speedy rashidi
if you don't know is the up and coming
dude in the welterweight division this
is why the Walter rate division is
moving forward this is why we needed Bud
versus uh Spence and Spence was supposed
to fight bud so they can uh make a one
unified King and these other kids can
come up and challenge for that so um
also we have boots and it's on this card
so you have boots on this card there's
another wall to weight that's in uh
right now the up and coming phase is
trying to become the king you know so
you have boots you have Speedy they both
won this card and then you have tank
with bubu this card is a knock it out
the park type of card fantastic card to
start the year shout out to the BBC for
giving you something in January that
other cards won't give you which is the
bang for your buck bubu was trying to
close this show on Nicholson
that's it fights over uh they're gonna
go to the score cards boo boo won every
round to be honest with you uh and you
know it was a decent fight in booboo
standards he hasn't fought in a long
time so he's getting back to where he
needs to be
so I do appreciate uh the effort to be
honest with you he's not supposed to go
the full distance with a fighter of this
caliber he's supposed to actually uh
step it up he was supposed to get the
dude out of there probably inside five
six rounds but I guess he needed the
rounds and regardless to what uh Booboo
needs to work off the rust so you know
Nicholson gave him a good one very
durable fighter a very strong fighter uh
stayed in there the whole 10 rounds and
gave him uh more than boo-boo bargain
for to be honest with you
what's going on Necromancer Zay
all right who has the fight oh um
pay-per-view PPC Showtime pay-per-view
uh go get that it's in there
um but like I said one of the main card
fights right now just happened so you
had andrade's versus Nicholson
um everybody knows him that boo-boo but
we know the tradition
so we know what we do what the hell are
you drinking on boat show yeah go go
2023 the challenge for sure all right so
what I have is uh vodka cranberry
All Eyes On The Rock
delicious fantastic
um let me see
I say because I love you like a brother
either do gray or go black not half and
half
okay yo
all right so you think
I left this here like like I I was like
oh man uh you is you don't go out and
dye your beard gray that's what you
don't do all right you just say uh I'm
not gonna die no more so I'm not gonna
die no more so you know the heads that
say we here for the fight they're here
to fight the great the gray is coming in
they got the the the blacks on the ropes
pause
um
and then these other guys they sitting
here fighting the Grays back so the
grace you know Winter's coming
the greatest gonna do what the Gray's
gonna do
my wife says I look like you know those
um what's those uh Chinese pandas the
cute little ones
[Music]
see this right here
yo Sovereign thought I was dipping my
bed to some type of uh black oil or
something like not bro
it's not how it would be
he said it's all crazy King oh God
that's what it is
black Ronin that's my dude all right
yeah yo listen that's the only thing
that mattered to me is she told me oh
Boo-boo you look crazy then it's off
you know nah I told you uh once my son
came over for uh Thanksgiving
I said I ain't gotta be Papi Chulo no
more let him do his thing
there's space in the world for him I got
three boys
let them do their thing
so
we got uh Vlad the Impala given the uh
the decision
boo-boo it's still undefeated sloppy
mess boo-boo Andrade
yeah he's decent he's decent
yeah you know um you know why he's uh
undefeated but you also know that he's a
sloppy mess so um
you know I don't see him beating nobody
like Canelo I don't see him beating
Charlo I don't see him beating David
benavidez and it's the reason why he
hasn't fought the top dudes in the
division you know um they don't it's
it's he doesn't command money
right so a lot of times it's it boils
down to how much money can you command
right how much money can you bring to
the table and if you can't bring in the
money that is necessary to get uh the
butts and the seats dudes ain't taking
no risk against you so it's a high risk
low reward when it comes to fighting Boo
Boo and you don't really want to you
know uh put it all on the line against
somebody that can definitely win the
fight you know because he's not a tomato
can but he you know at the same time you
know he doesn't bring in the money uh
hopefully with the PVC and Showtime oh
and he got cut he has a cut over his eye
so you know he stood in there longer
than he's supposed to
um
hopefully they can Market him better I
say give him at least a good three four
fights he needs to fight uh two times to
three times this year that let that eye
heal up really quickly get him back in
the ring probably by June July uh have
him with somebody in the within the top
ten uh by at least uh October November
uh you know have him in there with
somebody that's within the top five and
then next year have him in there with
the top three that's my opinion of it
but um again you know people evaluate
theyself a lot higher than um necessary
and it has absolutely nothing to do with
boxing skill has everything to do with
the draw what you're able to bring to
the table you know I'm not going to
fight you if I'm bringing everything to
the table and you're bringing nothing
you bringing no fan base that's not good
hey tomato cans baby
is it true Andy's fighting Wilder yeah
okay so the Andy Ruiz uh um Deontay
Wilder fight is in the works
and I think that's a great fight it's a
dangerous fight
is is is it definitely a dangerous fight
for Wilder it's an incredibly dangerous
fight for Andy but it's a wonderful
fight for both
because I still don't think that we saw
the real Deontay Wilder back uh you know
um that fight did he fight he he fought
his sparring part and he fought his boy
I think that was a check for his boy
because his boy was getting out of
boxing so
again you know so Andy Ruiz is not his
boy Andrew Ruiz is not a sparring
partner Andy Ruiz has nothing to do with
him so uh I I can see that fight
happening can Andy Ruiz upset him the
same day same way he upset uh Joshua
definitely that's definitely can happen
so uh is it is it is the fight gonna
happen I think that's deontay's next
fight I think that's the smartest fight
for Deontay Wilder to have to be honest
with you you know oh
iron Lord beanies get that in the store
it's crazy
tight nice and um if you don't like the
beanie go get the cap go get the cap man
stop playing stop capping go get the cap
tomorrow hayachi phase for all these
PlayStation dudes I got you on deck you
in trouble B
so we got Speedy rashidi up next
if you dudes don't know about speedy
rashidi
you are in for a treat
highly explosive very technical very
fast quick feet quick hands and he's a
pit bull in a ring if you could take a
pit bull and make him into a fighter you
will have speedy rashidi all right this
guy when when
Spence leaves the welterweight Division
and goes up to 154
um
this guy is going to give boots all
types of hell I want to see him and
Boots fight because him and Boots was uh
going at it at the press conference they
were sitting right next to each other
was crazy too you know um
rashidi you know went over looked over
at boots and they you know was going
back and forth and the rumor has it that
rashidi wanted to fight boots but boots
in them low ball rashidi for the fight
so rashidi turned down the fight and
boots is trying to talk that up like oh
you know like you turned down a fight he
said you lowballed me then he came and
doubled the offer on a low ball offer
that was garbage to begin with knowing
that he's not going to take the fight
sometimes for you to you can either
price yourself out like Bud did with uh
Spence or
if you don't want to do to take the
fight you can lowball them uh to a point
that is not feasible for them to take it
now some people said Spence people low
balled the hell out of butt and Bud
didn't want to take the fight because of
the lowballing offer so you know it's
two ways that you can look at it but it
always comes down to butts in the seats
and interest in the fight that's going
to make the fight right so I have a huge
amount of interest in Speedy versus
um boots I have uh see I'm not even
gonna try to pronounce the name the last
name of the the guy that boots is
fighting it's like chick sherikin and
I'm just going to call him Karen because
his first name is Karen so when we get
to the boots fight it's gonna be boots
Karen boots Karen and uh Speedy Ellis
versus uh Villa that's going to be the
next fight that is going to be
absolutely nuts and I can't wait to see
that that's gonna be something
completely entertaining for everybody
this is going to be probably the best
card that you're going to be able to get
in the first I don't know what is it uh
four months of this year
because you have uh Davis talking about
fighting Orion Garcia right after this
and Ryan Garcia talking about he's not
taking No tune-ups he's not taking you
know anything he's going to fight uh
tank right after this
um
I think this is a very tough to fight
for tank you know um
I miss you too Alex that's what's up
uh this is a very uh tough fight for
tank
this this this kid is no joke this kid
is undefeated for a reason uh he went
out there and beat Colbert I didn't
think he was going to be Colbert and he
put Colbert on his butt
um a couple of times uh you know the the
leak
um sparring footage of him fighting
Devin Haney that's Garcia fighting Devin
Haney I'm gonna talk about Ryan Garcia
I'm talking about uh Hector Garcia
fighting uh Devin Haney
um
a lot of times when you go into Spar and
this is the difference right sparring
sparring with headgear you don't know
what the day was and stuff like that
you're not preparing for one fighter to
build up to what you you're both are
coming in either out of shape or getting
into some type of shape to fight right
and in sparring uh like when I was
sparring they told me uh oh don't use my
jab when I'm fighting this dude just use
you know right hands and hooks and stuff
like that you don't know what they he
was told in between to to fight
um you know Devin Haney so again I take
sparring with a grain of salt unless
it's you know the Mayweather uh Dog
House type of sparring those dudes
getting it and it's like fight or flight
it's like you know single swim type of
thing so
is what it is let me see um
Devon devote surprisingly letting tank
have this fight after the situation he
had he ain't have no situation man come
on you can't tell Cat when you see Cap
all that was okay so this fight right
here was uh it wasn't selling like it
was supposed to it right it was the the
pot behind it wasn't like it was
supposed to listen uh rolly versus tank
rolly sold that fight with his mouth
tank don't talk
tank is just action in the ring tank
don't talk so Hector Garcia Don't Talk
Tank don't talk so to sell this fight
you have to sell this fight off the off
the the name of tank his uh his own
himself right so when rolly was fighting
tank at uh Madison Square Garden rolly
was talking so much mess he even had me
put a hundred dollar bet on him I'm not
even gonna lie I'm not capping I'm just
telling you what it is
um and I remember that fight because I
was on vacation at that period of time
and
I'm just like I just wanted to see the
fight the dude don't talk his way into
the fight and got his head punched off
his shoulders too right he got his head
ripped off right tank ain't gotta talk
tank is a version of Mike Tyson without
all the Jimmy jabber see Michael talked
the hell out of you Michael tell you
what he gonna do to you tank is a humble
dupe but in that ring he's a different
Beast he's a different animal right and
and you know Hector Garcia very quiet
dude so what they needed to do was uh
drum up some stuff
uh Tank's girlfriend ex-girlfriend came
out and told you that was Cap all the
way she she told you that it was uh oh
she made it all up because she was
jealous oh that doesn't mean nothing all
that was to sell a fight remember
any type of a news is good news because
it's gonna push interest and what
happened was the betting lines went in
the some of the better lines went up in
the favor of Garcia and because you had
tank coming out talking about oh you
know I might not even fight no more
after the Garcia fight I don't want to
fight no more make people go oh my God
this might be it I might get a come up I
might be able to pay off all this house
on his mortgage if I put 10 000 on
Garcia
let me see Godzilla get his head ripped
off his shoulders I'm not saying it's
gonna go that easy man I'm looking at an
eighth round knockout oh so if y'all
looking at any predictions I was gonna
say a prediction right before the fight
I gave you two a little bit earlier but
um Garcia is no joke man I'm watching
him right now and going through the
replay of him fighting Colbert and
remember Colbert took the dude for
granted Colbert came in there a little
bit flashy Cobra runs his mouth too much
and not not his hands so hopefully next
time
um you know you see Colbert Colbert try
to get his win back but then you know
Garcia went back and he fought Gutierrez
he was supposed to lose the Gutierrez
now think about it he's supposed to lose
the Colbert beat Colbert he's supposed
to lose the Gutierrez went out there and
boxed Gutierrez is off his shoulders
right
now you got tank
is three times to charm and can he go
out there and do this can he complete
this round robin
is he going is he gonna get this done is
he gonna get this hat trick
or or is it over for Cinderella
is it 12 o'clock and he gonna turn it to
a pumpkin
we don't know man but I know one thing
the more quiet tank is
the more you are in trouble
all right so
if tank feels that he don't gotta say
nothing oh let me talk about the racist
stuff Garcia said
let's let's get into the the racist
stuff Garcia said I'm expecting tank to
go out there and break this guy down in
in a way that you've never seen he was
standing up there with a bunch of
Afro-American
um
black Fighters
and he said he looks like a lawyer for a
bunch of delinquents
hmm
really
you look like a lawyer because he came
in there with that cheap ass tacky suit
you know the one you're going there you
buy it off the shelf you know the one
not the custom the one that hey man it
happened to fit because you was a medium
and he gonna say that he looked like a
lawyer for a bunch of delinquents
we have a barrier in this nation this is
black delinquent too you just look like
a more dressed up delinquent than
anybody else there
no but that's what was that was what was
said so no that what was it he put it on
Twitter that's what it said you need
then you need uh uh somebody that can
actually uh take over your Twitter you
need a a media person to take over your
Twitter you shouldn't be tweeting then
especially in this climate you know so
um I hope I hope he gets what he you
know supposed to get in this fight and
uh actually you know make peace at the
end of this fight but I'm like I know he
ain't say that and yes he did and then
they showed the picture you know what's
worse
it didn't look like that though
it did look like that it looked like it
looked like he was like yo he looked
like he looked like he he looked like
the mob boss and the dude the goons was
around him like you know what I'm saying
we're gonna handle our business and I'm
not gonna lie
my mother always told me just for the
occasion
right so when when you go into certain
things he was dressing for the occasion
and it sounded like his mother told him
the same thing just for the occasion so
maybe he was making a joke lighter the
conversation you know but again in in
this climate everybody's going to take a
picture or take a word and and twist it
around to uh something else but I saw it
I was like I know he said that I said I
but then I looked at it I saw the funny
you know I'm gonna find her funny and
everything
man I found a funny in it but you know
some people might not find it funny let
me see what's going on
uh Eyes under the hoodie what's going on
Happy New Years 108 Dragon four quarters
what's going on uh stop it unless you're
going to bring up Dana White and his
situation facts on that we already know
what you know what's going on with Dana
waiting them
um all I have to say is Dana White I
don't know who this guy is easy win from
tank not really
he said who's this Garcia dude take me
to bust that kid up for a few rounds
yeah so some act right I feel you is any
crazy Garcia would say something or post
something like that especially Hispanic
and Latino on God on God
on God
um he definitely
didn't read the room you know how when
you're going in you don't read the room
he didn't read the room
but it could have been ingest it could
have been funny
um sometimes people don't like you're
funny I know my funny comes off as
hurtful right PlayStation guys
but yo we got Speedy rashidi up right
now I don't think it's Envy uh Devonte
uh uh I don't think it's Envy at all I
thought it was just
he saw a funny picture if you see the
picture tell me what you think of the
picture when you see it and then get
back to me right
tweet me in it add me in it whatever
it was something that he saw
that somebody probably said you know
look at this but okay
you understand
sometimes jokes can be taken either way
and you know sometimes you know
somebody's joking ain't funny you know
humor is subjective
right so something funny to one person
may not be funny to the next person
right
and um and being that everybody's all
sensitive with the light and dark thing
you see how light she is compared to me
I'm not sensitive at all she just like
chocolate Paul's um what's going on
um I don't have much money but I want to
see this fight where can I watch the
fight or steal the stream pay-per-view
74 49.
who the hell is shooting about me try to
snitch what's up with you hey you
working for Sony Jim Ryan sent you to
get me oh God get out of here stop
playing like that cry baby uh true King
David you're funny doesn't hurt someone
hurt me sometimes it's a PlayStation
game
I'm sorry man I'm sorry Gabe but you
know I got PlayStation too King
streaming late night or Saturday let's
go let's go
let's fight not gonna be more than six
rounds I'm going with my my boy all
right hit that like button that's right
y'all gotta block that come on man how
y'all gonna put that up there I gotta
block that man come on man report this
remove that get out of here with that
come on stop playing man get that out
here
yeah
I don't know what that stream is but
don't do that man don't do that get out
of here with that hey
I gotta hire some snipers man I gotta
hire some snipers
I gotta hire snipers
clowns you up in the room baby you in
here clowns
let me see if clowns is in there yeah
four guys with quarter was in here one
away dragons is in him my boy came in
here I didn't even see him man yes there
you go yes sir there we go my bad my bad
lemon my bad
oh it sucks lemon ain't going with us to
um
to packs this year man
my man ain't gonna be there
we ain't gonna have to have um
Whatchamacallit block Brothers this year
so we'll be doing block brothers from E3
man
he said God said clearly a PlayStation
gamer
he said sorry I didn't want to invite
the spammers nah you ain't invite them
let me take the hat off enough promo
my head getting hot pause
remember post your drinks tell me what
you drink and what you sipping on I
think
um
so Speedy rashidi record is 24-0 with 15
knockouts
I think this fight is going to probably
be one of the most entertaining fights
of the evening only because
if he don't look like a pit bull baby
you know act like a pit bull baby
this boy right here
got everything that you want in in in a
young hungry fighter
hungry fighter
he got Latinos training him
all right
and
homeboy is just on a whole different
level so right now he's fighting
probably one of the wildest dudes from
Argentina
Villa looks like he was supposed to be a
modeling he's super symmetrical
but
oh God you know you know when to do too
handsome and he fighting you you better
be able to fight you better be able to
fight
all right so here we go here we go round
one you see I don't I wasn't even gonna
call this fight but oh God I got to call
her Speedy rashidi all right so Speedy
starts off with the jab uh Villas taller
than Speedy so you can see it in the
height Speedy going he's punching up to
the Target all right so right now
they're both in the center of the Ring
Speedy circling uh to uh Villas uh left
jabbing head and body
nice Jabs he looks like uh Hector
Camacho uh Hector Camacho body used to
be
like very very dope a right hand from
Speedy uh right to the body
uh from Speedy left to the body from
Speedy jab he keeps his jab pumping so
um High guard uh jab stays out there
like a whip uh when Villa closes and
Villa's taking a lot of shots and not
tossing anything back so that's letting
you know one or two things Villa saw
something when he was uh
training form and he's trying to time
Speedy or he's trying to slow the fight
down and get Speedy to go at his Pace
all right so and he's walking Speedy
down without throwing any punches Speedy
is backing up throwing Jabs right hands
now uh Villa throws a jab and goes back
into high blocking guard as Speedy uh
circles to his left alright so he's
circling towards um Villa's power hand
which makes no sense to me but he's
going left and right so you have a
speedy again high God jab right hand jab
double jab very early very end very out
left hand right hand speedy again and
Villa High guard walking him down throws
a jab every now and again uh Speedy goes
to Villa's body to back him up make
Villa reset
all right so Villa closed distance all
right so Villa is a box of puncher right
never seen Villa before this is the
first time I'm seeing Villa and um
he punches Speedy on the back of the
head
close and he's he's crouching coming in
Speedy is backing up throws right hand
he's moving from side to side uh this
the is a dramatic difference in size
all right Villa is towering over speed
he has Speedy in the corner speed he
turns out throws a jab to the body jab
up top
all right and Villa is walking Speedy
down he has Speedy up against the ropes
hit Speedy with uppercut and the left
hand speed he turns off the ropes he hit
Speedy with a right hand speed he turns
Speedy Jabs him back to the body
right hand and Villa is up close comes
over the top speed he spins all for
ropes right back to the center the ring
goes right back to the jab and round is
over
very telling round
Villa uh can handle the speed and uh
Power so far of Speedy and he's able to
walk Speedy down and close the distance
without throwing punches
that's troublesome
all right so what what I would tell
Speedy to do is land clubbing right
hands uh to keep Villa um resetting and
spin them but spin them in the ring
don't let them back you close to the
ropes and then spin off the ropes spin
them in the the center of the ring that
way
um
you can actually uh use it effectively
let me see what's going on
Dr Pepper
Jerry straight
Maker's Mark that's what's up Diet Pepsi
I had a tequila and some beer boy you
trying to go down you said to killing
some beer blocked on OJ that's my dope
all right so all right so there we go
Speedy Lanza one two backs up uh Villa
he goes to the body Villa says come on
come on that's what he wants I I'm
starting to believe that these dudes in
Argentina drink tequila as babies as
soon as they come out I believe that
these guys are probably the toughest
roughest dudes uh next to some Mexicans
that I know ooh body shots from Villa
left hook they're fighting they're
banging inside Villa is throwing shots
to murder somebody and I'm telling you
right now Speedy is there for all that
murdering because he's turning and he's
moving throwing right hands it's such a
good fight so far as in a strategic uh
thought process of the fight because you
can see that any one shot can um
actually end this so again the fight
takes off uh in the second round the
same way it left off uh Villa walking
Speedy down Speedy fighting countering
off the ropes Speedy's on the ropes
right hand from Villa uppercut from
Villa Speedy hose on and Villa looks
like he's in more controlling Speedy
even though Speedy is landing more
punches all right so Speedy's throwing
the jab inside the guard right hand left
right hand left from speedy and Villa
sweeping left hook all right
Here We Go Again backing up right hand
so that's what I said land clubbing
right hands left to the body all right
here we go jab from sweetie uh Villa
pushes in and misses speedy speedy grabs
him turns them walks them out lets the
referee break them up they're right back
in the center uh Han Speedy throws right
back to the jab so it's more like a uh a
stay busy jab and then a hurting jab all
right and all right so Villa is throwing
left and right Speedy avoids them uh but
he lands a left to the body Speedy spins
off the ropes right back to the center
clubbing right hand left hook from
Speedy jab in between the guard from
Speedy I don't know how much of this
that Villa can take because Speedy is
going top and bottom left to the body as
he spins Villa tries to go Speedy grabs
him smartly walks them in the middle let
the referee break him up right back to
reset
all right we got 33 seconds left in
round number two all right strong jab
and you can see
um Villa tries to land the uppercut but
he missed nice jab from Villa he catches
speedy speedy comes in catches him with
a short left and he digs straight to the
body he goes right back to the body and
he goes right back to a hook to the up
top and goes right back to a jab you can
see the difference in the pedigree of
the fighters right now in the variant of
the of the punches Speedy has to out of
necessity and uh Villa doesn't have to
at this point because he's wearing
Speedy down without throwing punches
again a carbon copy of round number one
but Speedy did a little bit more at the
same time Villa cut distance more so
they're fighting in such a close
distance that Villa has the opportunity
to land shots I don't think he will land
shots right now probably after the fifth
or sixth round it'll really heat up
he said tequila sounds good right now
game going was good hit that like button
that's right
block Brothers salute Lords that's right
brought to know J we got 35 watches we
got 29 likes let's get that to 35.35
let's make that a 50 50 Shake 35-35
let's go get those likes so that means
we got people in here that ain't hit
that like button love you hit that like
button we got 30. there we go let's go
um
yes
tank is smiling talk about you ready to
party you about to get in here get busy
with these Knuckles he took party ready
apart you got to be scared with a
godsend fight is a party
all right Speedy back there all right
here we go back to the center of the
ring this is where Speedy wants it in
the center of the Ring Speedy doesn't
want it up against the ropes
all right so a little zest is out of
Villa's legs as far as walking Speedy
down and the rate that he's doing it but
he's back there okay oh good nice right
hand from Villa Speedy still keeps that
jab pumping in Villa's face keeping him
busy right hand over the top clubbing
right hand from um Speedy double right
hand from Speedy one two from Speedy all
right uh Villa goes to the body left
hook right hand oh right hand from uh
Villa back Speedy up jab from uh Villa
oh he misses the right hand again jab
from Speedy to the body
job up top from Villa jab from Speedy
the exchanging jabs back and forth while
uh Speedy is backing up again but Villa
is being more active with his punches
clubbing right hand left hook from
Speedy off the turnout all right hard
pivot left hook right hand from Villa
left hook to the body from Speedy
Speedy's trying to catch him under the
ribs from that jab nice jab he's trying
to get him to worry about the body shots
more than worrying about the headshots
he's trying to set him up for a club and
right hand over the top
jab remember I said that right hand from
speedy speedy is setting them up for the
right hand over the top left hook to the
body from Speedy as he spins out nice
Jab
you have uh Villa tapping him Speedy is
going up and down I remember I tell you
guys levels with these Jabs you got to
give up and you got to give a down with
these Jabs he's given uh the body he's
moving he's seeing exactly what he's
doing he's fainting right hand moving
speed he's moving from off the ropes
back inside back to the jab Villa's
stalking him Villas trying to land the
body in the overhand right and he
catches speedy and Speedy spins out
while he catches him with a right hand
goes right back to a jab up jab again
catches Villa on the lean in
Speedy is working very very hard here
but it's very easy for him because I
guess he's used to jabbing like this in
training nice job Villa comes through
with a left hook to the body overhand
right Speedy back to the jab all right
all right there we go we got 30 seconds
in left and around the Villa's missing
wildly with shots as Speedy is standing
there moving a slight jab uppercut uh
Allah raise erotic nice jab from Speedy
nice jab to the body from speedy speedy
steps back uh Villa tries and land shots
10 seconds left in the round Speedy is
still boxing mm-hmm now he's able to
time him speed he is and Villa is
looking slower a foot as the rounds go
on
kind of the same thing as the first
second and third but again
we're seeing Speedy set up different
things so I think the the key to this
fight is going to be the overhand
clubbing right to catch uh Villa coming
in
and Speedy is going to continue to throw
the Jabs to the body into the head very
in Heights changes the directions of
your eyes and when you change the
directions of the eyes of the fighters
you change his mind his mind has to
reset at all times
all right there we go less sir what's in
that cup bro
vodka cranberry on rocks the Chalice
babies the chop golden chalice 2023 yes
it is
let me see what I'm seeing
them Baltimore cats don't play tank is
ready for sure
yeah I know of course I've watched it
why come on string a bell that's how I
knew about this guy and um when I found
out that Stringer was from London blew
my mind I thought he was from New York
all day kind of crazy I was telling my
wife that uh it'll just Albert blew my
mind
when I found out he was from London I
thought that dude was straight up from
New York City you heard me
the way that he handled himself is way
that he sold that role Stringer was
crazy boy right so they back again
sent to the ring same as before Speedy's
jabbing up and down jab I mean the the
boy got speed and power all day
um but Villa is no joke and it's what I
thought it was Speedy tried to land that
right overhand that like I said uh right
there he's setting them up now his jab
is getting long all right
and uh he's he's putting the jab out
there with full extension and um he's
feeling good about the jab all right and
he's throwing the right hand off the
pivot Speedy is in his element right now
now you've seen he's warmed up into the
fight this is round four like I said
round five and six the fight should
really heat up he starts to really see
the repertoire of both fighters to be
honest with you overhand right oh off
the ropes Speedy these dudes is banging
in in in this round round number four
looks really good because uh Villa is uh
throwing overhand rights and left hooks
to the body it's not like he's not
fighting people he's fighting and it's a
different way that he's fighting right
he's fighting in the manner of putting
Supreme pressure on speedy and Speedy
must fight right Speedy must do things
to keep this guy off him because he's
winging punches at speedy
back to the body from Speedy over the
top from speedy
all right nice jab from speedy Speedy is
being very consistent with his uh with
his output right and he keeps trying to
land that overhand right I think that
overhand right is gonna be the right
hand that either gonna put uh Villa down
on the floor or he's gonna
um at least stun him with it
around nice push off Villa gets close
but he's not Landing the shots that he
wants to land because they're coming up
the middle he didn't set up enough over
the top shots to land those under the
cut middles all right oh Speedy Lander
uppercut and he caught him Villas are
hurt right now Speedy is going in for
the kill Speedy is landing shots Villa
he's punching in between shots now
Speedy twisting it Speedy's putting
Villa up against the ropes really he
tried to finish with the overhand like I
said nice jab from Speedy what I told
you he's a pit bull he's a Pit Bull with
speed I told you who this guy is man
he's a killer Hawk got 21 seconds in a
round overhand right he's clubbing him
with the overhand right but Villa
catches him with an uppercut pushes him
back make Speedy reset Speedy's back
Speedy gotta reset nice Jab
there you go there you see Villa had
something to keep Speedy off him
what he don't know
he heard Speedy with that uppercut okay
so Speedy had to back the hell up
because Speedy was a full attack mode
until the uppercut good round it was
better fight is heating up to the point
of a a good knockout is on the way but
Villa got caught with a nice left hook
from speedy
spend off right there and uh Speedy's
back to jabbing him all right Speedy
started feeling himself and he's gonna
catch him oh nice left hook to the body
but he's catching them close
so he the body was there but you know
the face was open and the Speedy catches
him bang again he's turning these shots
from the hip from the hip
from the hip beautiful shots beautiful
shots I love it all day
but Villa's there to fight you know and
this is where you can tell the mark of a
man is in between that hurt he was able
to land that uppercut to get Speedy off
him
all right here we go round number five
I told you this place is packed for this
fight everybody is packed in there right
now usually right now dudes ain't in
their seat yet man if you missing a
speedy Ellis fight you're ridiculous
there's boys the up and coming he's the
future of the Ring I'm gonna tell you
man Walter weight division is in good
hands he reminds me of Sean Porter Shawn
Porter had skills
you heard me he reminds me of Sean
Porter of Sean Porter actually wasn't a
football player
this is who he reminds me of so we all
know the heart of Sean Porter but Sean
Porter never had the skills to go with
it speedy rashidi is that dude
oh that left hook was crazy oh God
terrible
terrible
so they back at it again and it looks
like a carbon copy of the first four
rounds
you know Villa's coming in he's walking
him down and the only thing that I would
tell Villa you got a jab a Jabber all
right you got to match that jab with
that jab you gotta come fire with fire
but um I guess he he chalked it up as a
loss very early and felt that the only
way that he can win was up close all
right so that puts you at a disadvantage
because you're supposed to be as
versatile as your competitor all right
but uh
he keeps winging shots that takes more
out of you and Speedy's Landing all his
shots straight up the middle right hand
over the top and he goes right back to
the long jab you're giving Speedy too
much extension on his Jab
he's trying to catch Speedy coming in
and it's very hard to do so
all right so he's he's he's hunting
Speedy I'm telling you man he's closing
distance on Speedy but he's not giving
Speedy anything to uh to to be wary
about
you know the guy is strong
he's on Speedy in the corner and and and
from the outside looking in you would
think that you know he has Speedy weed
wants him but no not to be
Speedy's back to jabbing long jab two
because he has the wide stance he's not
happy he doesn't have Happy Feet like he
did in the first two rounds Speedy is
standing there and he's Landing the
right hand and he's able to dip in and
out he landed an overhand right over the
top like I said the overhand right is
going to be the Clincher that he's going
to be the deal sealer in this fight
but uh Villa is trying to land these
shots the jab is just becoming too
devastating to be honest with you
nice stuff jab from Speedy Villas coming
in and Speedy is land in the same time
Villas throwing a punch he knows that
that's the way to take the power off the
shot land right before the shot hits
take the power off the shot
all right nice job
uh-huh so all right so right now Speedy
is playing catch and Pitch but catching
pitch is what I told you guys before
catch the shot you pitch right off the
top see he's playing catch and Pitch so
everything that uh Villa is throwing and
Landing Speedy is catching and he's
pitching right off of it so he'll throw
the shot after he catches it so it's
it's it's very beautiful to see that
this guy is so well trained as a fighter
and and it's it's nuts I I know y'all
could tell that I'm high on on this
kid's boxing Powers because I think he's
very good I think he's the future
let me see let me let me bop these dudes
out of here get out of here
we got 37 we got 35 I like that ratio
that's good that means tour you guys
aren't doing what you're supposed to do
please please
hit the like button
you save kittens in Argentina please
hit the like button
come on she has two of you y'all know
who it is
what's going on dead proof
there we go now it's just one of your oh
there's a lot of you guys showed up just
now
[Applause]
let's get it
round number six five and six I told you
here you go
there we go fights heating up we got
Speedy doing this thing nice jab from
speedy
oh oh Villa's showing some skills now I
don't know what they told him in that
corner oh he told him
nice job oh what's going on he looked
like a whole different dude he switched
out his brother jumped in oh boy looking
like Ivan Drago right now I don't know
what the hell just happened jab he
walking in he looking more relaxed what
did he need somebody gave his daughter a
Red Bull or something what's going on
he looks like a different guy wait a
second wait a second
who is this dude
they must have told him you don't win
this fight you can't go home you gotta
walk home who Neo
oh he's out there trying it now boy
so he's coming in he's coming in nice
jab like I said what I told you got a
job with a jabber overhand right under
the body let's go Villa is working this
round like he likes like somebody told
him his check depended on this one
oh boy putting the jab in nice stairs I
like the bent knee there we go there we
go Speedy back to that jab say ah shut
up
there we go speedy turning them oh there
we go hold on Villa's walking him in
there we go he's okay so what Villa
wants to do he wants to turn him from an
uppercut into a left hook right so he
wants to bring the head up and bring it
over and
it's that's a good strategy but he has
to do what he did he started the round
off with with was the Jab
set that up with the jab I honestly
think all that can work if he goes with
the jab but now he's back to walking him
down
and Speedy's making fun of a mocking I'm
missing shots mocking them you know so
me personally though I honestly think
that the jab works better okay
I see the difference now
when Villa goes to his Jab
he gets into a jabbing posture the
jabbing posture is not a defensive
posture he doesn't feel comfortable
jabbing with somebody with Speedy speed
I see it now
nice job from speedy
right hand off the spin out
and they going right back to the same
formula so when Villa Jabs
he locks his right hand to his chest
and he goes to the jab and then the
right hand becomes less effective so he
wants the right hand to be more
effective so he stays away from the
jabbing posture alright so when he goes
to jab he locks his right hand to his
chest and he Jabs here right so he can
move his head on the stick that happens
in training if somebody teaches him how
to keep his right hand here
and he moves his head while he's jabbing
it'll work better
it's it's little tiny things like that
when you're training that show up in the
fight and and remember again
it's what you're comfortable with like
so if if you're comfortable with
fighting with your hands down that's
what you're gonna do
they have to break these habits in you
excuse me
out of you in the gym they have to break
those habits and he has that's a very
bad habit
yeah what's going on
Jesus Christ
what's going on Salute
Dana White slap that like
I said puppet
he said like Dana White smack that like
button we got 40 likes and 41 watching I
like that racial I mean one of you dudes
ain't doing what you're supposed to do
please do it I like it please save the
puppies in Argentina
they're back at it again
round seven Speedy tries to land the
overhand right
Villa comes up the middle
very good very good stuff
all right so see Villa goes to the jab
and goes to the body of Speedy he's slow
and Speedy down and this is where he
wants to fight to be he wants to fight
to be
in the later rounds
why Speedy slows down you able to land
those shots you're hunting Speedy the
same way you was hunting Speedy before
right
and now you can Jab
his strategy might work
because I mean I have him losing every
round up until this point but if your
your thought process is to win by
knockout the rounds don't matter yo he
just ran out of that corner like he owed
him money
where my money at speedy
so Villa now is closing distance with
the jab shorthand and throwing uh
swinging looping shots all right so uh
Speedy is gonna have to fight for his
life for the rest of these 12 rounds all
right so he got five rounds to go and
you have this clubbing dude clubbing you
in the back of your head clubbing you in
your side of your body clubbing you all
over
and he's walking him down this guy is
not hard to find oh all right so he
catches Speedy to the body Speedy was
moving his feet at the same time made it
look like Speedy got hit real hard well
he didn't
um he just lost his foot and Speedy
catches him with a double right hand
over the top nice jab while uh Villas
coming in see
he locks his hand again he does the same
thing he hits Speedy low a couple of
times
this guy said stop complaining and fight
he's
he's trying he's trying his damnness to
kiss speed he's mad as hell as speed he
said
yo this is so good this is such a good
fight
this is such a good fight so uh Speedy
is a counter puncher at this point and
um nice jab right hand uh Argentinian is
throwing the shots over and under
I give Villa all his uh Glory
but it's just not enough there if he was
using his jab better he can actually
make this into a different fight all
right to land those big shots you must
set up the little shots and little shots
set up the big shots and this is what
happens
gotta stay with it gotta stay with it he
wants to land these shots he closes the
distance he does clubbing shots he has
Speedy up against the ropes but Speedy
is countering off the ropes he catch
Speedy in between the shots but Speedy's
catching him so it's like a wash in
between round over eight rounds in
and it's looking like Groundhog Day
right but I'm not saying Villa ain't
trying I can see him changing the pace
of the fight but what he must do is jab
jab is as fundamental jabbing is what
you need
he's got who uh okay black and OJ King
who you think is going to win Davis or
Garcia okay okay
um
eight rounds
if it's gonna be a knockout it's gonna
be within the eighth or ninth round
right
that's my opinion of it I think it goes
12. I think it goes distance
I think it goes the distance I think
I think I gotta respect Garcia enough in
uh his last two fights with Colbert and
uh Gutierrez that uh
he shows the fortitude the willingness
the determination the pride of a
Dominican he shows it right so I respect
it so I'm not going to say that he's
Awash and he's he's a bum because he's
not he's on his uh his first
pay-per-view headline gotta respect them
um if it's gonna be a knockout remember
I said it's the eighth or ninth and
that's by Tank but uh 12 I don't see
tank losing this fight
but I see I can see how Garcia can make
it a fight that's going to last the
whole the whole 12 rounds I can see that
I can see that happening
so fight uh the round started they're
back to the same ways
uh Villa walking in without the Jab
and when he does throw the jab he locks
his right hand to his body
and it's such a shame that he doesn't
see it he turns into two different
people it's he's like uh Dr Jekyll Mr
Hyde when it comes to fighting because
he looks like a totally different person
when he goes from stalking to boxing
and he has to marry the two the two have
to become one in order for him to make
that transition into that a great
fighter
you know you can't be a battle of
Duality within yourself in the middle of
the Ring that's not the place you want
that to show up at
nice jab to the body
oh nice jab to the Head from speedy
and you know Villa is stalking him man
I'm telling you he has a lot of things
that I like as a as a stalker but he
doesn't have the jab to seal the deal
and Speedy is just backing up jabbing
him to death
oh nice right hand over the top he
caught Speedy but Speedy catches him
with an uppercut on the inside
remember Speedy has a good chin as well
so you know the jab from speedy and he
sees the right hand coming because uh
Gutierrez Villa telegraphs it so much
he telegraphs a lot of his shots being
so tall you can see the bend at the hips
you can see the dip of the shoulder you
can see a lot of these things ahead of
time he doesn't know how to mask him a
jab will mask all of that
all right so he comes in he weaves in
his hands is low
uh Villa's still stalking
as uh
Alice walks him Alice is walking turning
being very calm with his shots now
nice job from Villa catches speedy
Speedy holds him walks him to the ropes
15 seconds in the eighth round the round
is pretty much a wash uh Speedy goes to
the body Speedy goes to the head all
right
um You can pretty much tell exactly how
he's gonna land his shots
good good good good round it mirrors the
other rounds remember it was just one
round I think there was a sixth round
where I said that they must have put his
check up for grabs where he just came
out so they're showing uh boots boots is
another good fighter let's let's
just let's let's let's
call it a buck
these two fighters is the next
welterweight division uh leaders
you know until she caught Stevens and
these dudes Devin Haney and tanking them
go up to Walter weight
these two dudes are the ones that are
gonna hold down the welterweight
division as far as uh boots
and
I'm not even going to try to pronounce
uh Chuck and Zhang Zing uh boots uh
fighter like I said I'm going his name
his first name is Karen so I'm calling
Karen don't think I'm being rude by
calling him a Karen all right so don't
even come for me B unless I send for you
47 watching 45 likes that means it's two
you guys holding hands not doing what
you're supposed to take your hands off
each other and pulse and hit the like
button save puppies in Argentina with
the kittens we gotta save them
let's get it
let me see what y'all saying over there
Hector Garcia looks like the peoples
from the shaft movie yo
you know you you know you're ridiculous
for that right he definitely do
shut up you gotta kill me
yo you know I thought he was really
Spanish
I really thought he was Spanish
think about to give peoples a shot of
pause hey yo dookie kicks come on man
you gotta get that
hey you
they call me peoples because I take care
of my peoples
[Laughter]
yo y'all out of control
that's why I like the messy Lords the
messy Lords is definitely in the
building shout out to the messy Lords
what's good baby
oh they gave Villa the last round I
didn't
guess you got to give them something
right
and as wild as the end you got to learn
from something right now
if you're going to give uh Villa the
last round then you got to give Villa
the whole first eight rounds right
because he fought the last round the
same way he fought the the last eight
rounds
same exact way and Speedy didn't slow
down Speedy is actually doing the same
thing that sweetie's doing actually
Villa is landing more up close shots now
in this round and the right hand that he
just landed on um speedy speedy is
backing up
and uh Goodyear a good yes why I keep
saying Gutierrez I don't know what's
going on but Villa
is landing uh the jab in this round
that's the difference
he's throwing the jab and he's trying to
land a straight right hand that's the
difference oh good shots
oh uppercut
yeah yeah yeah
so uh Villa landed the best shots in
this round so far
and um
very good very good from Villa all right
it's a very good good job from uh oh
nice right hand oh left hook uppercut
all right he got Speedy legs wobbling a
little bit what I told you Speedy
throwing those shots here we go now
we're into that fight we talking about
we got 14 seconds left Speedy's catching
him coming in but he's catching speedy
speedy looking over to his corner corner
saying go ahead Speedy Walk That Out Boy
Walk It Out Speedy Walk It Out Speedy
throw that right hand over the top it's
three seconds left speed he said bye
baby
catch you next round you ain't gonna get
me not today sir
somebody throw some water on that man
golly
pass me that
thank you
I gotta take some of my Speedy Shake
Speedy gonna figure it out
yeah now that round you get Villa
Lulu Chang versus Ling Chang who you got
you you talking MMA to me
you talking who you talking to you
talking
oh you got me confused with funds shout
out to Fonzarelli uh uh bruh I told you
I call it the butt naked choke I'll be
telling the wrong stuff when it comes to
MMA you don't don't get it twisted
what's up what's up hope everybody's a
20 down anime that's my peoples on
guarding them they back Best Buy done
got him already uh ready he he ready
he's ready for the 2023s gotta go to him
make sure I get my TV game right no no
no TCL either cause my boy out there
with the real TVs he see the real TVs
he'll tell you the truth
tell him dip down
these dudes talking that TCL crap throw
them in the bushes on God
oh oh he's on Hill speedy speedy and
fight this guy off
Speedy said man if you don't get out of
here with all this he on Speedy man I
told you what I told you if he gonna go
get speed he gotta get Speedy late he's
taking Speedy into deep water he trying
to drown Speedy he trying to he he you
know black people can't swim this is the
rule right that's what they say right he
trying to take the Speedy on the D
waters come on Speedy show him you learn
from Michael Phelps let's get it speedy
he walking Speedy down
oh nice left hook from speedy speedy so
get up off me he said shut up speedy and
take it pause
nice job what I told you what was the
difference the jab he started jabbing
Speedy now he's leaning on Speedy that's
what you're supposed to do jab him hit
him lean on them
thank you all right Villa uh-huh Villa
tried to click Villa tried to take his
head over that shot go ahead whip your
head boy oh he going for it son gotta
respect this dude he here to take checks
boy all your checks give me all your
checks my mail them Brooklyn dudes when
I had to get my some of you check in the
summertime
run Son run
they'll be waiting for you boy go to
that check cashing place if you're there
oh
oh man he got Speedy hug him
56 seconds oh he owes me he got Speedy
in the corner he got sweetie and Corner
Speedy fighting this dude almost said
please
Speedy wish it was 10 Rounds only
it's 12 Speedy sorry you wanna play with
the big boys
nice job oh man you know boots gonna
talk hella crap after this especially if
boots when his fight well
oh hell yeah Villa Villas I told you he
looked like Ivan Drago just Argentinian
nice oh it caught Speedy with a nice
right hand oh Speedy quarterback Speedy
ain't trying to hear that this was in a
pit bull get hurt they out here fighting
that's what I'm talking about here we go
to the body to the Head bro body head
bro left hook all she digging in is like
not today Satan not today
I took that flight round over B
his head's still looking good
boy supermodel out here fighting
Victoria's Secret in the face
boy on Deck let's go let's go no tcl's
in that house so that's right dip down
tell him hey help
laugh out loud I appreciate the love
King that being said anyone needed TV
come see your boy who we had Ramen
tonight on God yo get my man off that
Ramen stop playing get over there get
that TV Best Buy we got the hook up my
boy doing that for sure dip down anime
no playing and his channel is dope too
go sign up over there King David will
Jake Paul lose a boxing match in 2023
King David what's up positive desires uh
28 was going on verb brizzle what's
going on for sure
yo if if he fight Andrew Tate if he
fight Andrew Tate this year that L going
down for that boy
if he fight Andrew Tate
but I don't know round 11 of a highly
entertaining fight
this is deep water right now the
speedies and deep water uh Villa is on
him pressing the attack Villa is trying
to win
and he's trying to win by KO uh Speedy
is uh shortening up his shots Villa is
throwing everything at Speedy up the
middle over the top around the hooks
everything is power shots from Villa all
right so Speedy just fell on the floor
villagers pushed him down I honestly
agree with the judges head that uh Villa
has won the last two rounds right but
remember I gave Speedy all the rounds up
until round eight right so you gotta say
from there is Nip and Tuck but These
Guys these rounds he's clearly winning
right because you can see the difference
in speed you can see the difference in
stalking ring General ship and and Villa
is definitely Landing the more telling
shots you always got to ask yourself who
the hell you want to be at the end of
that round and if that doesn't if you
don't want to be the guy that got beat
up then you know who won the round
that's all
Speedy definitely getting the most out
of this fight I gotta give respect to
Speedy for taking this fight oh he
should have threw the shot Villa should
have threw that shot I think he would
have landed that shot
a nice jab from Speedy they back up
against the robes Villas closing
distance overhand rights Speedy slipping
under he still seeing shots he's still
very clear in his head he's still going
with the jab and he's still throwing
overhand rights and he's spinning out I
can see Villa getting a little
discouraged with certain things because
he wants to trap Speedy but Speedy is
getting his back feeling the ropes and
he's turning off of the ropes not giving
Villa uh the clear advantage that he
wants with the ropes on Speedy's back
all right so Speedy's back to jab and
soon as he feels the Rope he spins right
off the Rope he goes from side to side
he turns on him he's jabbed and he moved
nice beautiful jab a villa didn't get a
chance to set up right hand alright so
this is Jim's stuff right now but he's
doing the Villa this is what we do in
the hood we move we box we spin we turn
this is all that he learned all right so
remember when I told you that he had
Hispanic trainers Hispanic trainers from
the Bronx taught me how to grab pull
tuck and roll which shots and this is
exactly what Speedy is doing
right he's throwing punches he's
spinning nice jab right hand hold
spin get out of the corner push back jab
and move
beautiful stuff I love this part of
boxing because this part of boxing is
what you really learn these are the real
fundamentals the little tiny things that
you don't get a chance to see that you
don't really know what's going on in
there they're both doing high level
stuff right now all right and beautiful
round 11. I gotta give that that round
again to Villa I think Villa is winning
the the championship rounds because he
set himself up to do so but that setup
is a losing strategy very good Corner
though his corner is telling him
everything that he's supposed to do
foreign
sloppy King he gets hit and he he's his
heart and he's durable and tough that's
what we need though if it's a no-go with
T-cell what about Insignia imma throw
you in the bushes straight in the bushes
you're gonna get out of here I don't
know my man said he senior don't do it
player bid is on point Victor thank you
so much sir King evening good sir will
me scream what's going on watching the
fight with you that's my dude Villa
looks like he's warmed up and got
comfortable after the layoff after
layoff
yeah so listen
round 12 dudes hugged in the middle of
the Ring that's mutual respect but that
don't mean he ain't gonna try to kill
him
all right so Speedy throw one two three
Speedy notices his last round so empty
the gas tank
empty the gas tank here
you would have thought that this was the
main event it's not wait there's more
nice nice job beautiful stuff man both
of these dudes
our Champions and it's not gonna be a
draw man all right so you got uh Villa
stalking speedy again he's coming down
on Speedy he's throwing the the right
hand Speedy is going to the jab and
writing him and spinning
see that that's the biggest thing you
have to spin off your shots right hand
spin
jab right hand
spin
nice right hand oh right hand from
um Villa
Speedy is taking the jab from oh he
dropped Speedy with a left hook he
caught Speedy backing up drops Speedy
with a left hook kinda knew it was
coming because the jab was there look at
Speedy eyes Speedy said oh ish I can't
believe this
boy said surprise
welcome to prime time baby oh he's
hitting speedy speedy don't look good
it's a minute there's some change Speedy
you better hold baby it's a minute some
change oh he is Speedy with some stuff
oh Speedy is down on on the Maddie slip
Speedy trying to drink oh Speedy oh no
Speedy Say It Ain't So
Speedy oh he said Speedy with an
uppercut right hand Speedy trying to
hold hold on
say hold on man hold on on God man stop
playing man stop you making me look bad
hold on Speedy hold him Speedy he got
Speedy up against the Rope he trying to
land shots please
going back to the jab Speedy you better
grab this man oh he grew up oh oh
he hitting him with that left hook oh
Speedy oh Speedy fighting leaning on
Speedy oh oh the referee got 33 seconds
this don't look too good Speedy come on
man this is the 10A round oh he hugging
the hell out of them Speedy hold that
man
22 come on and then talks you up Speedy
hold him Speedy oh oh god oh sweetie
almost went down again
Speedy come on 12 12 seconds sweetie
hold on nine eight seven six five four
three two he drops speedy again he drops
me again that's a 10 day round
whoa round over he said um baby
round off
it's me yo you haven't been running you
haven't been jogging and you had that
last mile ago this is it fight song for
booboo
oh
Speedy just made it oh god oh that
Argentinian
oh
[Music]
shout out to the dude
oh God and them
Speedy don't you give this man a rematch
you take your win and you go home
sweetie
oh God now if you're scarred it like I
scored it
if if you actually got the score how I
scored it
speedy speedy can't win I mean sweetie
can't lose but uh
man I'm gonna tell you this
you're gonna focus on your fights now
you ain't gonna start talking Mr Boots
yeah you better go get that eye a hug
hug him and tell them I'm never gonna
fight you again
you hug them and you're doing like take
the pit bull cruise that was a good one
you'll never see me again
[Laughter]
some of those fights man you gotta win
and get the hell up out of there
whoo
bad boy is poison
you can't trust that hair with a smile
that boy is poison
yo he tried to come there he tried to
come to America and take that wind back
oh baby
boy Speedy sick oh my God they're losing
Argentina
what the hell he hit me with it was a
left hook baby
[Laughter]
he gave him the spicy ramen noodle
he hit him with the oh yeah
left hook right hand oh
oh
my God he said excuse me is this seat
taken
so oh he kicked me ref he kicked me
I said right hook left hand
oh my God that was that was that was
that was beautiful that was beautiful
that was beautiful
best commentary in the business that's
what's up this was going on Wow Jesus
good fight Speedy seeing a whole lot of
tweeties poison
this is better than a professional
broadcast God bless God yo he was trying
to speed he threw his stuff to the room
he was trying to try to kill sweetie
sweetie jumped to the bottom of the Rope
said oh now today Satan not today Satan
you won't you won't take me out of here
Bill's the bub you won't take me out of
here
oh my god oh throw that chin boy imma
tell you now Speedy gonna look at this
tape and he gonna realize
I'm never fighting him again
excuse me he did everything right
for eight to nine rounds
and find itself in this position
in the 12th and final round
I told you that guy came in with purpose
from round one
and he was walking him walking him
without a jab I told you
when he can walk somebody without a jab
that don't bode well
and if he was jabbing coming in but say
now I understand why he wasn't jabbing
because he Chambers his right hand when
he Jabs
they have to work on that and training
to
be fluid
up top
turn spin be fluid here right here
everything has to be fluid right so you
can't just lock your right hand in when
you're jabbing and just let your jab
hand move and this is what he's doing I
don't know what tape he saw I don't know
who he's working with but you have to it
has to be like a ball right what what
they used to train me with is they put
um this little medicine ball hair and
they train you here with moving it right
moving it here all right so that teaches
you to keep your hands here right and
then we work with the three pound uh
weight and we move here with it and you
keep everything tight here right so then
when you're fighting when you're in the
ring
your happy place is here your hands are
trained to stay up here you don't
chamber in your right hand and lock it
in because when you need it you need it
to fly from here wow and you turn off
boom bop bop right can't do that if it's
chambered to your chest because they're
going to see it come off your shoulder
you don't want that you don't want that
seam coming off your shoulder
all they gave it a draw told you
hold on
oh he beats speedy
Speedy loss
Speedy loss
let me tell you this remember when I
told you if they gave him that one round
then they had to give him the other
rounds so now you have to look at what
the the the the the ring judges is
looking for right
he was walking Speedy down
right so if you thought Speedy won all
those early rounds with the jab and
movement then fine but if you thought
Speedy lost one or two of those rounds
with the walking down
then when he excuse me was really losing
in the 11th and the 12th round
then that's the problem right because
you can say in the 12th round he lost at
least 10-7 that's three points
that's kind of crazy
that's a huge upset
no you can't Telegraph
there you go
see that's why you know me and will know
will know will knows fights
wow it that that was that was something
to see if anybody got a chance to watch
this fight
um you know boo boo went 12 rounds
or 10 Rounds
Speedy went 12. if if this was a 10
round fight and wasn't Eliminator uh
Speedy wins the fight because the 12 and
11th round doesn't happen uh and Villa
doesn't get a chance to close the gap
right uh
I'm honestly gonna tell you boy
um
the most I would have gave I would have
gave it a draw
but again
like I said if you can give him any of
those rounds
you know you have to give him the the uh
some of those early rounds too and
Speedy didn't help himself in the last
round
with
um
how to just uh stay out of boxing
distance with him
I think he should have established a
little bit more forceful fighting early
when he had more strength opposed to
later on in the fight when he didn't
because remember Villa forced him to
exchange in certain instances where I
don't think Speedy wanted to exchange
and if Speedy would have exchanged
earlier and tried to take some of the
zip out of uh Villa then you know that
then you probably have a different fight
or a different outcome to the fight
right
wow one of the pieces is off the table
and not saying that okay one one loss
doesn't uh
um
determine the career of a of a fighter
right because Canelo lost to Floyd very
early on and I'm not saying Villas are
Floyd right but uh Canelo lost to Floyd
very early on
and uh Villa well you know now Speedy
needs to have the rematch with old boy
I wouldn't have wanted that
I'll tell you that now
all right so let me see uh dying
all right this is the best place to
listen way better than ringside God
bless baby
if I had a nickel for every time at
Argentinian spoiled the promising
upstart boy this is true
last round that was a three knockdowns
well it wasn't three knockdowns they
gave him two knockdowns one knockdown
was encountered as a knockdown but
regardless of what let's say if you did
count it right even though
I say he was winning around you got the
knockdowns let's say it was two
knockdowns and he was running around
that's a three-point round you can't go
more than three points anyway you can't
give a 10-6 you can't give uh uh a 10
something 10-8 around the most they can
get
um
that was crazy
that was crazy but again did he not earn
it yes he did did he not take everything
that he was supposed to take and not
give up yes he did he took everything
and he he did everything that he was
supposed to do he went in there uh
fighting uh
a favorite
and I'm not gonna lie he went and took
it from the favorite he took it
that's what hunger smells like remember
when I told you when he came out in that
sixth round it looked like somebody told
him his check was on the line
oh boy changed everything up from there
everything up from that sixth round from
the sixth round he started to try to
dictate stuff he started to use the jab
he said he got comfortable later on in
the fight because he wasn't too
comfortable early on and I think the
speed is what
um dictated that the speed of Speedy
if if that kind of makes any sense the
speed of Speedy
changed uh the dictation of the fight
and once Speedy still slowed down some
um then he was able to time them
this is why you have to change the
speediest shots um I learned this from
Hector Camacho
never through the same punch at the same
speed
and when you do that it's harder for
people to time you
right so
um this is not the end uh for Speedy be
honest with you this this is honestly
the beginning
um but if everybody ties you're winning
and and and yo yo yo your value to that
oh
your value is not uh in that oh right
your value is in what you bring to the
fight if you're exciting enough
right
um
he's highly entertaining very exciting
was it a bad matchup I don't know this
is my first time seeing Villa so I've I
don't know how he fights so I don't know
if they they
if they mandated this fight for it
and he didn't get a chance to see how
Villa fought or you know um if he
watched uh boxing tape on Villa what he
needed to do
was force Villa to back up
he never forced Villa to back up
and he never had Villa on his back foot
Villa always fought off of his front
foot and Speedy was fighting from round
one on his back foot
the dictation of the fight and the pace
of the fight was brought by Villa you
see what set it up that jab like I said
the jab set up the hook to the body and
a hook to the Head
no jab no win
that jab he wins beautiful
yes
Venezuelan or Argentina one of the two
interesting I never heard that throwing
speed technique before yeah well
it's off speed punches
right all boxes
um all all boxes not punches see there's
a difference box of punchers boxes
um if you're a pure boxer
it when you hit the bag it's a rhythm
and you hit the bag with different
varying speeds and punches and power
right and some takes a lot from you some
take a little bit from you
you don't want to give everything at
that at certain points you want to vary
the speed you want to vary the timing
you want to become
um unpredictable and the moment you
become predictable that's when you're
like a mouse and a trap right
you don't want to be a mouse in the Trap
so you vary the speeds you vary your
height you jab to the forehead you jab
to the middle of the face you jab to the
throat you drop to the center of the
chest you jab to the belly
vary your Heights and your Jabs so they
don't know exactly where it's coming
from right what you're trying to do
it changes so
I was a boxer puncher wasn't no Mike
Tyson you know
um
you you could say more like
whose style I I like the the most
um
Evander Holyfield Style
right and when I got a chance to see how
Holyfield for it because I love Larry
Holmes as a kid I thought Larry Holmes
was the greatest thing since sliced
bread I thought his jab was
God in a glove
right so
um you know you see uh Sugar Ray
Robinson I know I was no Sugar Ray
Robinson I don't care what nobody said
nobody Sugar Ray Robinson I think God
took his time off and came down as a
human form and just was beating people
up
um you know with Sugar Ray Robinson
ridiculous do absolutely ridiculous I
don't even know how Jake LaMotta even
stood up to this guy but um
you you you you learn and you know
um
Holyfield
had beautiful left hooks beautiful right
hands jab determination a blue collar
dude right
and you know that's exactly what um
he was about let me go get this stuff
out of here
jeez I gotta report these dudes
I haven't seen this much uh activity
on my feed and well since the Canelo
fight
these dudes is overhead tank must be
bringing in those numbers
you know anytime I put those hashtags up
that's a boxing match you know
if it's if it's a top level dude the
Bots come in
try to get y'all to go to these sites
put in your credit card and you'll
realize that you're broke later
thank you
let me see
let me see let me see what's going on
all right three knockdowns
oh he back again hold on
watch it free
all right got all those
96 wins in a row as the kid Roy Jones Jr
was my guy for sure at 174 Sugar Ray
Robinson that's right
174 on one secondary Robinson whenever I
had these trades piston like jab I think
of one person Larry Holmes on God
on God you knew Larry Holmes was a
terror
you know an absolute Terror in his
division he will never get the credit
because that's the guy that comes after
Muhammad Ali and beat up Muhammad Ali uh
so he wasn't a well-liked dude and he
had an attitude and a personality that
you know didn't make him one of the best
loved um
Fighters we have uh boots up next
um so boots needs to walk out of here
with one of these uh we need one of
these water weights
to uh actually uh win you know I mean
this this is this is a um this is a
fight card full of Fighters that can win
lose or draw right and we saw our first
loss tonight you saw boo boo fight to a
decision and that wasn't an easy fight
for boo-boo uh you know my wife thought
he got knocked down
uh and this ain't gonna be an easy fight
for tank and it's not going to be easy
fight for boots you know so uh Speedy
learned the the hardest lesson of the
evening uh don't look ahead look at
what's right in front of you eat your
meal that's in front of you don't worry
about desserts sometimes you might not
make it there
right so you you got to stay focused on
your prize
King when is the new boxing game coming
out fight night that's my ish they
announced a new boxing game like two
years ago still waiting you talking
about that um
oh the boxing game is in beta
I forgot the name of it I don't like it
I don't like how the punches hit
remember the first time we saw a fight
night and how Fight Night looked and I
think they have Roy Jones and Bernard
Hopkins it was in on the 360. and they
gave you the demo which is 360 or they
they send a demo out
and I I remember me and Cog playing that
game man we lost our minds because the
way the punches hit in the deformation
of the faces uh it looks so real
um I can't lie that was that was
probably the Pinnacle I mean I started
boxing games from ring King from um NES
right so that was crazy the afros you
hidden with the left hooks right here
dope and then you had uh punch out super
punch out
um
great stuff great stuff all the way
around the boards but then we got to the
realism because you know
um if y'all see our intro uh they we in
our segments each guy's segments his
games that we pick
um mine was Evander Holyfield's boxing
for the Genesis uh Dope Game
um then you had uh ring Kings
oh I had that for Super Nintendo in
Genesis
all boxing games I was just a fool for
uh this last one I don't like how the
the fighters look realistic I don't like
how the punches land
and um
I just I hope
that they fix certain things of it like
hit detection
body deformation uh as far as when
punches land is like you know how the
gloves deform and the punches I mean we
had this technology from the 360 right
so why can't we have the same technology
uh in these uh consoles that we have now
which has more computing power more
speed more resolution more Fidelity why
can't we have that so hopefully we can
have those things uh going forward I
mean I just think it's possible we have
53 watch and 55 likes I like that ratio
more than I like the other ratio before
when one people wasn't doing it uh it
seems like two people left he'll be back
baby you went to the bathroom I got
faith
your Wi-Fi went out it'll be right back
let me see
now I mainly rock with that Creed VR
game yo that game is crazy uh me and my
wife were supposed to be playing uh VR
for New Year's that didn't happen we was
playing other VR games that demo dropped
uh during the CES presentation I
remember that demo yep finally remember
to catch a streaming game and that's
right Deez what's up
knockout Kings hell yeah knockout Kings
remember Green Guy Code we ran the
Holyfield boxing hell yeah
I think there was a knockout Kings in
2000 with Ali on the cover loved it
can't forget ready to rumble
ready to rumble was my game I had the
afro dude the skinny afro kid
he is fast as hell man that jab Came
From the Bottom
hell yeah man you got that from I got
that from my Dreamcast Dreamcast
launched with 18 games that was the only
console that I brought day one with 18
games day one went home Hydro Thunder
ready to rumble
oh I gotta look at the list of those
games
all right so we got um
I'm not gonna tell you
his name is changing
his name is Karen his first name is
Karen is Mama call him Karen I'ma call
him Karen
uh so don't think I'm being rude
Karen is fighting boots
kind of crazy it sounds nuts
but uh yeah
boots is up next
this is a card
these guys has got me working hard in
2023 very early usually I only talk
about the last fight
I don't I have never
never called
the the
what was it um
man this is this is this honestly is
either to be honest with you because
this has got to be the three-headed
monster because you had Speedy versus
Villa first fight boom could be fighter
tonight
damn sure could be upset of the night
now I'm gonna tell you right now
if Karen can come in now and be boots
that'd be crazy that'd probably be upset
of the night
but then you got Garcia versus Davis so
if Garcia can pull that off that's upset
of the year
the hell would upset of the night oh you
can't trust this corner that guy got on
a suit jacket with a t-shirt don't trust
him check his water
suit jacket with a t-shirt that guy's
from another country
[Music]
let me see what's going on here nah
greatest heavyweight hell your greatest
heavyweights is though power Stones fire
got to be upset of the facts on that
Dave
Your Eyes under the hoodie I think that
is nuts that's a crazy name greatest
heavyweights for Sega yeah
boots is coming out now I don't know
what are you wearing
who designed it he looked like a peacock
mixed with an ostrich
[Music]
[Laughter]
gotta respect the dope hey man everybody
got their own flavor then he chewing
that bubble gum with that chew to the
side like that like your Uncle Larry
[Laughter]
his last name is boots
well I mean boots innocent
uh I don't know what is I don't know
maybe as a kid he used to walk around
with his father boots on I have no idea
boots
I don't know why they call them boots
you know what I gotta figure that out I
gotta find that out Andrade you said
Andrade look good
stop it man Andrade can't look good in
fights he's sloppy as hell man he has a
laser left hand
you gotta respect them
I just think he's a a clumsy sloppy
fighter
that is a mess in the ring and he was
supposed to get that guy out earlier
than he did he didn't get him out at all
he went 12 rounds
um
agree to disagree perhaps
remember final blowing arcades hell yeah
it got pointed to the Genesis as Buster
Douglas boxing game
I got to play still I got to still play
it I love the Dreamcast that's what's up
um
let me see
Buster Douglas boxing came about
nobody expected him to beat Mike Tyson
right
so when
he won
dude just like we gotta Market this dude
fast because we don't know if his next
fight he gonna lose and if he gonna
fight Mike Tyson Mike is coming back to
kill him right so but he signed the
fight Holyfield he lost anyway
lost anyway he went for the bigger bucks
lost anyway he didn't want to give
Michael run back
um
and it was a rematch clause but I forgot
what happened
I think Mike had to go to rehab or
something you know was behind the scenes
stuff I think Mike had to go to rehab or
something like that to get cleaned up or
whatever because oh we all know going
into that fight he didn't train he
wasn't he wasn't right he was on some
drugs or whatever whatever and uh
allegedly allegedly so I don't get sued
allegedly and then um
you know he wind up losing uh TV and the
Holyfield and you know Mike never got
that rematch that he wanted you know on
Buster you know just went on you know to
to whatever
you know I don't know Buster got he got
his cash out he got his money
he said it Andrade more sloppier than
poison yo will you wait my man Kings was
going on
Andrade is worse than Sean Porter
Shawn Porter
has
he's not sloppy on purpose Sean Porter
just looks like if if you take a
football play and throw him in the ring
right with some form of fundamentals
that's what then you have Sean Porter
Andrade
I think he trains that way to to to to
be that type of effective in in his
style that's his style his style is not
a pretty style so I think
um
I think his style is more conducive to
the sloppy nastiness that you you get a
chance to see so I don't know
so we got boots right now 290 one note
um
no decision
and uh 27 knockouts
boots is a crazy dude
boots is a crazy dude
last dude I talked up lost that was
Speedy
so all I'm gonna say is I don't want
booze to lose so all I'm gonna say is
boots is a wild dude
you got that ostrich peacock suit on
and he got fringes under
his godson made that fool
oh that's my dude right there
all right here we go
let me see what was the last game you
played
Mike was wild in Japan eating all kinds
of stuff yo you stupid I'm not gonna
mess with you dookie kids what was the
last game I played I just played uh
Sonic Frontier
yeah y'all hear about that tomorrow
y'all are here about that tomorrow
Bruce look see
now this is the difference
boots is the bigger guy
Speedy was not the bigger guy in his
fight and the size difference told the
story I think if Speedy was fighting
somebody his height he would have had a
hell of a time he would have had a great
time
he fought somebody that was bigger
obviously stronger a little bit more
durable
didn't work out for him so
here we go
round one boots and Karen I'm not gonna
say Chuck how to get gun
not doing it I'm not doing it
[Music]
all right wow that's a long name boy oh
all right so boots throws Jabs boots is
meeting them at the center of the Ring
not backing up uh Karen likes to move
from side to side has a good jab very
good jab very good right hand what the
hell I've never seen this guy fight
before boots putting a jab on them
trying to slow him down walking them in
all right
um this guy has a lot of nervous
movement uh boots squares up uh catches
him or remember boots switches Styles so
boots is orthodox and Southpaw so booths
goes right back to Orthodox and he
switches from Southport to Orthodox
that's what makes boots very different
all right so he's like uh Crawford in
this way where he can switch from
Orthodox into uh Southpaw and he does it
on a dime so
in one minute he'll be uh with a
right-handed jab and then he'll be in a
left-handed jab so you have to really
adjust yourself to boots you have to
make boots square up so right now boots
is trying to walk Karen down with uh the
jab and he's doing it from either stance
either posture right and he's moving
across uh the ring uh trying to cut him
off not trying to give him an angle now
sometimes that could be confusing to
some Fighters but if you train for this
type of uh movement they do this a lot
in the amateurs you can really uh
prevent the guy from moving too much uh
By just making them square up
so uh boots throws uh a jab
and a right hand and he switches and he
goes right back to South Pole so he's
back in the Southport stance right now
and he's throwing a right-handed Jab
I don't know where he's more effective
from I think he's more effective from
conventional whereas uh Crawford is more
conventional uh more effective from
Southport
so um right now boots itself poor
and
and he switches and he goes right back
to Southport
but I think he's more
um
effective from conventional
so boots is cutting off the ring so as
you can see right now the difference
right now uh from the Speedy fight is
Boots has taken the lead right so he's
the boxer but he's the stronger guy love
you bless you
um he's a stronger guy and he's uh
walking down carrying with these shots
um
and he's you know he's back into the
center to the ring throwing strong Jabs
strong Jabs
and it's it's just really more or less
uh boots slowing them down first round
is over it was boots uh switching from
South Pole to Orthodox South Florida
Orthodox doing strong Jabs trying to
just dictate Pace uh
I think boots is gonna stand the whole
round
and in between rounds
all right so
pretty decent
much love fam back to the Best Buy grind
tomorrow 2023 will be fire for the Lords
have a great night God bless you brother
if I made a boxing game what would you
call it and would it who would be on the
cover King
um
I made a boxing game
you know we already had greatest
heavyweights uh we already had uh ring
King we already have uh boxing Legends
[Music]
um
my boxing game will be called ten toes
down
and it will have
um
who would I have on the cover
who would I have on the cover of ten
toes down
ten toes down
I'll probably have
um
Sunny listing on the cover
uh if anybody knows me they know that I
think Sonny Liston
as the most feared heavyweight to ever
touch this Earth
I think Sonny Liston was an incredible
monster of a man
uh the
probably one of the most feared boxes uh
to ever walk this Earth
um him Jack Johnson Jack Johnson was uh
in the era Jack Johnson was fighting
Jack Johnson was a Savage like a pure
unadulterated
uh like these men was like hard as still
pause so you know it would probably
either be Jack Johnson or sunny
listening I'm I'm one of those dudes
that respect the the whole mystique and
aura that goes behind it yeah you're
gonna see him
um Muhammad Ali or Cassius Clay beat uh
Sonny Liston yeah he he yeah he did he
didn't fight Sonny Liston in his prime
and that doesn't matter it's just you
know my opinion of the fighter who I
like the most that's about it but right
now um so
um Karen is given a good account of his
self by giving boots tons of angles by
moving in and out
and boots is jabbing throwing right
hands now can this work in Karen's favor
to keep chipping at him from the outside
um yeah he can possibly do something
with this because what he did was he
just landed a couple of shots on boots
and boots is missing a lot of shots
boots had to grab him to to hold him in
front of him just then so yeah
um
he's throwing shots and boots is missing
boots his Landing Jabs to the body into
the overhand
um
but he's in and he's out
nice Jabs and he's staying true to form
he has a good smooth boxing technique
very elusive
uh very nice very eye-pleasing to be
honest with you I love his boxing style
you know like he puts his hands where
it's supposed to be moves his head at
the just the right time he gives a lot
of shoulder movement he spins out when
he's supposed to
he's a very very competent boxer uh
Karen is
absolutely nuts to be honest with you
because he is the one that's Landing
some of the best shots in this round
um and the round is over
can this strategy in this style uh be uh
boots Kryptonite
he's moving he's giving boots
ton of movement and I don't think boots
was ready for it because I damn sure
wasn't
but he's given a hell of a count of
himself
wonder if Karen keep up this leg work
for the rest of the fight that's what
I'm thinking Cypher I don't know if he
can keep up this level of movement but
if he if he can keep up this level of
movement for 12 rounds that's absolutely
nuts that's possible that it can happen
let me see
we got 55 watts and 65 like I'll take
that I'll take that out buy that for a
dollar this is round three
now I know you're gonna say this is like
um a downgrade from uh the last fight it
really isn't is the tale of the same
tape right
you have a favorite versus the underdog
and as a favorite versus the underdog
um all right so boots is uh stepping up
uh his game right boots is trying to
close in on Karen and Karen keeps moving
nice Jab
from boots nice right hand but these
shots are missing
right all the shots that boots is
throwing is missing he hasn't landed not
one shot cleared that I've seen so far
but Karen is there when he wants to be
and he's not there when he don't want to
be
it's it's it's kind of crazy
um yo this dude's footwork is bananas
it's like he has this uh this sixth
sense of perception of where boots wants
to throw and when Boots throws he's gone
and he lands his shots and gets out of
the way
boots is throwing double Jabs right hand
uppercut good catches carrying up
against the rose when Karen spins right
back off into the center of the ring and
he has movement
I love the movement because this is the
thing that I do with my knee and my my
hand
and I and I and I tell uh my wife every
time I hit the bag your first your your
first foot your your left foot is tied
to your jab right
as that left foot goes so does your jab
goes boots catches him with a right hand
and he spins off
but I see the same movement as that left
foot to that jab and he turns out
and he's there
right there it's like he's like he's a
mongoose fighting a cobra
and it's crazy to see I'm telling you
right now I've never seen him fight a
day in my life
I've seen boots fight plenty oh he
catches boots with a one two three
and steps over
when I say one two three that's a jab
right hand jab
and this dude is bouncing on boats
jab to the body he's comfortable enough
to jab the boots body
he's right there
he's like a magician right
so
he's in punching distance
and he's catching these shots and he's
pivoting and it's like boots catches
them with a hard left
and he spins he grab boots and he turns
boots around
and remind you these these shots that
boots is catching them with is few and
far between
right oh and he catches him with a right
hand at the end of the belt
now
I do not know how this is being scored
if I'm I'm scoring off of what I'm
seeing
this guy is it's he's like Houdini he's
being there without being touched he's
spinning without being hit he's punching
and he's not being hit in return so he's
given without receiving he's turning
he's pivoting throwing shots and when
Boots throws back he's gone he's he's
like he's vapor
it's absolutely crazy to see
and I'm pretty sure that he got a lot of
you guys looking like what the hell is
going on
because I think he's lulling boots to
sleep
because if boots gets comfortable with
his movement
and doesn't attack him I I don't know
what to tell you to be honest with you
because I think that then if he's
waiting for boots to show some form of
tiredness and then he goes in I mean
this dude could be a long distance
runner for all I know
and he can keep this pace up all night I
don't know
but he's he's when Boots reaches in he's
there for the counter right and all I
can say is he looks like a mongoose to
me sometimes the Cobra catches the
Mongols sometimes the Mongoose catches
the cobra but at this moment right now
the Mongoose is playing Mongoose games
and the Cobra keeps lunging and the
Cobra being boots
the Cobra is more powerful the Cobra has
venom
but that Mongoose though has those
little razor and he catches Boots three
times fourth time and he spins out on
boots
and Boots has to hold them to hit
he's doing what seemingly The Impossible
he's doing seemingly them he's Frozen
boots boots has frozen like my screen
[Music]
yeah my boots is trying to get him
but
he has boots Frozen
not wanting to move
all right so I see what his strategy is
his strategy is like I said kind of like
Villa strategy lead boots wear himself
out lull him into a false sense of
security
and then all right so boot slows him
down gets him up against the ropes and
goes to the body and goes to the Head
and that was the best series so far that
I've seen from boots all right and
he's a boots is closing the gap on him
trying to close the the gap on uh Karen
but Karen still is moving
and he's right back on his toes
goes right back to the Jab
and he moves catches boots gives him to
the referee like take this back I didn't
order this
and Boots goes right back to the oh
right hand from Karen it's very sneaky
very subtle things that oh straight
right hand
and he's trying to catch boots he's
testing boots his chin
hmm nice right hand right hand from
boots
and Karen spins back off goes right back
to the center of the ring and he's
giving him different styles of boxing
all right so he gives him the
cross-handed and he gives him the one
two all right so this guy is very well
versed at being a very technical boxer
right
and let me tell you the traps that he
set up soon as this Bell is over for
round four this is round four mind
you're going into round five
all right now he's playing mind games
with boots he does this cross-handed
thing right and he and Boots thinks his
hands is locked
he switches his feet which turns his
hips and when he switches his feet and
he turns his hips he shoots the right
hand and catches boots
automatically
right so everything is dictated in his
boxing stance
that's his posture
next right hand
everything is dictated from his feet
so the feet goes to hands right so this
is what he's doing
he has very fluid feet
very fluid hands
very good head movement all right um
Stephen Felton on the screen
um
I'm I'm
baffled to be honest with you I haven't
seen a guy box this natural and this
smooth and keep this up for this long in
a long time very different very
different and this would let you know
the PVC puts together some of the best
cards because they don't you know they
have Champions that can lose right they
put them in highly competitive fights
this is not an ESPN this is not a disown
crap these are these are fights where
the champion can actually lose and right
now Karen is doing
seemingly The Impossible
right spinning turning jabbing moving
giving angles to boots
in such a manner
that is dazzling right boots hasn't
landed solid stuff yet but this guy
keeps chipping away
nice right hand from boots boots catches
him on the counter he comes around the
body but it seems like Karen has a chin
and he backs off and Spins back out on
boots and this is where I think the the
switching switch hitting uh hurts boots
because he wasn't set to throw anything
from that position right
and he was able to turn out and spin out
he goes right back to the Jab
this is absolutely crazy because boots
has missed almost every shot I mean I I
know copy box has boots probably at a 12
to 15 percent of Landing shots
where as you know Karen is probably more
at a 48 on Landing his shots
but Karen is not throwing a bunch of
shots he's giving him a lot of movement
and then when he does throw shots he
throws shots where he's in position to
get a high percentage shot right so it's
a spin-off right now so like he spins he
catches boots against the ropes and
catches boots with a right hand and the
overhand left and boot shakes his head
just says this doesn't hurt but we all
know that means boy got me
uh he spins right back off goes right
back to the body I love the level of
spinning and knowing exactly where he is
in his space his space is here
and he keeps everything here
all right so it's it's beautiful okay so
now he freezes boots and he turns them
and he gives him a lot of foot movement
tells them come on and fight give me
hand and and he spins off jab Jabs and
he misses this dude is a a different
type of dude very elusive very different
he's giving so many angles and I'm gonna
tell you if he can hold this up and he
can keep this going for 12 rounds this
dude can come in here and snatch a win
and because he's Landing these right
hand he's Landing these Jabs he's
Landing the left hook boots catches him
with a double left hook and the round is
over but again who do you want to be at
the end of these rounds
I'm not gonna lie I want to be Karen
I'm not gonna lie
tell you the truth
let me see
I wonder if Karen can keep this up and
you can see he said King David what are
you telling us Karen is actually winning
never heard Karen get so many
compliments on God
hey yo you know why I I can't I can't
pronounce his last name and I'm not
gonna do an addict I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna butcher your boy's name
like that so his mama call him Karen
I'ma call him Karen
boy this dude is something special I
don't care
win lose a drawer this guy is a treat to
see
nice nice boots catches him but a nice
left inside and then you know
he's elusive this this guy's a mongoose
he's the new Mongoose man it's really
good really good looking like Willie Pep
in there and who knows Willie Pep
anybody knows Willie Pepper if you ever
seen Willie Pep fight this guy is
fighting like like Willie Pap man and I
know that's High Praise but I'm telling
you look at his foot movement look at
his hands now I'm not saying that he's
Willie Pap I'm not saying that he's the
new Sweet Pea what I'm saying though is
Willie pip had a style right that he can
hit somebody and don't be hit he can be
right there and don't get hit he got hit
with two shots right there not saying
that Willie Pep never got hit but this
dude right oh that was a beautiful new
look throw he looked like Danny Garcia
when he threw that no look uh right hand
oh and he he has a stabbing jab that he
throws to the belly button
it's a right hand that he throws right
so boots throws the shot and he's just
out of range he just dips his head he
just moves his body he just moves his
shoulder he's right there but not there
how frustrating is that for somebody of
Boots's caliber to be in a ring that he
thinks that this guy can't uh you know
shine his shoes type of thing and this
guy is in here actually Landing shots
and Boots has to think he has to hold
him to punch which is what he's doing
right now
this is kind of crazy you know boots is
pouring at the jab he's trying to walk
him in he's trying to land something
under over the top and here comes Karen
yet again one two three Karen lands a
left hook over the top and Boots head
turns all right so he's trying to freeze
boots and and and hit him with shots
he's trying to Dazzle him same way of
mongoose dazzles a cobra or a
rattlesnake you know
um it's a dazzling technique give him a
lot of faints
all right and when he lunges soon as he
stick his head out you bite him in the
back of the neck
and this is what he's doing every time
boots comes in he lands his shot he
turns we have a two dollar Super Chat
from Hollywood Hollywood rules sorry for
the late party Happy New Year my brother
do you uh happy oh yeah sorry for the
late party Happy New Year my brother to
you and the fam keep doing your thing
Ant-Man trailer new IOP tomorrow facts
Hollywood rules with the five dollar
Ultimate Super Chat God bless the new
guy for the new year thank you so much
love you
boots is missing these shots man
and I and I see it I see it I see it
it's Claire's day I see it as clear as
these glasses gonna let me see
and y'all can see my eyes right
I can see what's happening
nice right hand nice right hand one two
the fighters he know what is it with
this sixth round that these dudes come
out looking like somebody said they
checking clear
something's going on yo he caught Bruce
with a one-toe something going on
somebody I don't know who's over there
telling them Yo they said they're gonna
hold your money who said that
oh yo this is crazy
Get Your Shine boxing and this is
completely out timed them it's complete
yeah completely all time yeah for real
for a while boxing name Elemento Mario
was looking like the new slickness that
was hard to hit but he fell off early he
wasn't disciplined good overhand right
definitely
it looks he's okay so he yeah they're
tiny dudes they tiny dudes they won 35
those are tiny guys
I got a thigh that weighs 135 pounds
no not really but I probably got two
legs Daddy there you go
dear God man
I know boots didn't think that he'll be
at this round right now with this
situation I I can tell you that I can
tell you that on God
all right so here we go here we go again
here we go nice Jab
this kid right here yo I'm telling
anybody if if you ever want to see
anything look up Willie Pep and you can
get the closest approximation of this
dude right
um and that's that's that'll let you
know how vast my box and knowledge is to
go in I'm not saying Willie Pep wasn't
the strongest puncher Willie Pep wasn't
the hardest hitter but Willie Pat would
slick his oil
right and this dude is slick as oil
right he he just has a sixth sense about
him let me find out he's Spider-Man
this dude is out here doing things I
mean they give him boots every round I I
disagree I mean I totally disagree with
the whole thing but we we also know that
Speedy was supposed to be getting every
round before right on God so
continue to watch the story the story or
tell itself at the end
this is dope right here
this dude this dude and he's here okay
so now
so now he's there to be hit but uh he's
backing up and he's getting in his
stance and he's throwing right hands so
he knows to catch boots coming in right
so he blocks really well he blocks
really well so before he was slipping
shots right so now he's blocking shots
and boots is coming in so he's given
boots
um
something to feel like he can hit and
when you get comfortable in doing so you
let yourself open up a little bit more
like he just did he quite boots with a
one-two turned him and and held him
right
very very slick stuff boots is throwing
uppercuts inside trying to get Karen
Karen is moving and he's he's slopping
it up right now
sent to the ring seven round
all right
he's throwing a One Two Boots is holding
on them they're breaking them up in the
middle of the Ring
nice spin off and they're right back in
the center to the ring boost throws a
one two catches them
boots is back in the center ring
and
there's a one two
very uh and and and there goes Karen
again one two three
so he's given as good as he takes he's
moving from side to side and boots is
holding and trying to hit trying to get
a feel
of of Karen to know where where he's
going to be because for seven rounds he
couldn't find this guy
his jabbing he's moving
he keeps his uh his jab hand out there
to deflect shots shoulder movement
moving from side to side
that was probably bootsy's best round
and that's not even saying much to be
honest with you all right because uh
Karen is still moving from side to side
he's moving in and out
um
okay we got uh Vargas versus Foster we
have Humphreys versus Stevens that a
hump Hill person Stevens that'll be good
uh January 20th February 11th
pretty good stuff Friday we won't be
covering that but we'll definitely be
covering uh the Saturday February 11th
fight
let me see let me go
all right so nothing new good overhand
right
pretty good stuff pretty good stuff I
know everybody will pack in right before
when the Davis uh fight kicks in
the building is packed
um
I know we expected a lot more fireworks
from boots in this fight but remember
Styles make fights and boots is a boxer
puncher right more of a boxer and he's
fighting a more slick boxer than him
right nice jab from boots boots is
shooting the jab out there
some of the job is missing
and then
you know Karen goes back on the bicycle
back to throwing Jabs to the uh right
hands to the body now Karen is stalking
boots he has boots up against the ropes
and you know boots is trying to change
uh his fortune I don't think that's a
good idea with Karen all right being the
the reason why I don't think this is a
good idea taking this tactic and letting
Karen lead is because Karen's been
wanting to lead the whole fight but what
he wanted to do was he wanted boots to
make that decision
right being as good as a box that Karen
is that's a terrible idea boots has to
continue to be the lead
keep pushing Karen back and he's doing
that right now jab right hand carrying
to throw a jab here and there
when you go back to using his feet all
right so nice jab from boots keeping
carrying at Bay
and uh he's he's covering High guard uh
boots is while Karen turns him throws
right hand jab right to the belly
and right hand left hook from Karen
right hand from boots right hand from
Karen they both uh hug in the center of
the ring and Karen gives them right back
to the refs boots misses wildly with a
shot and they tie back up and they go
right back to the break
you have a minute 14 left in this round
overhand right from boots overhand right
from boots
um left hook
oh okay Karen Karen is moving in and out
something to behold I love fantastic
high level boxing
nice jab to the body from boots
nice overhand right from boots
now not saying that this stuff is
landing I'm saying this stuff is thrown
you know left hook inside from Karen
all right
left hook from boots left hook right
hand from Karen
and then he ties him up and he let the
referee break them up Karen dips in dips
out very low dips in one two three from
Karen boots blocks a couple of those
and he's stalking them boots Karen
throws a one too and goes to a right
hand from boots but Karen is not dead
boots goes to the body Karen is slick
enough and to fill on which side boots
is going to roll until he rose is to the
opposite side throws a right hand boots
throws a left Round is over
Karen spins out
um
I will give that round the boots
but again I'm telling you we're at a
place where
um Karen is doing
a lot of movement a lot of hand a lot of
foot a lot of hand-eye coordination a
lot of head movement
and that stuff can uh lead to
frustration excuse me
from boots I I think boots is going to
be a little bit frustrated
when you get to the 10th round
let me see honestly the way Karen is
controlling distance is nice boots is
going all in on power punching yeah he's
wild he's going all in on the power
puncher and and you you gotta you can't
front on how Karen is moving because his
movement is
wasn't expected
it's a pleasant surprise it's like when
you get that indie game when you get
that vampire Survivor I understand
there's a little hot lofty praise that
when you get that that that game
that's like wow I didn't expect that the
Game Pass special
and it's like it's dancing on him he's
dancing on them because boots is coming
out trying to be the champion and he's
trying to move in and out and he's
trying to walk this guy down he's
jabbing he's just not there
you know
boots is trying to run him down
and then he holds him pushes him off
waits for the re referee reset back to
the jab movement movement
and he look right hand left hook boots
catches him with a uppercut and tries to
walk him back down boots goes to the
body
the boots goes to the right hand boots
is trying to walk him down nice jab from
boots
Karen steps over
resets step in steps out nice left hook
to the body
all right nice
job from boots
nice job from Karen right back jab right
hand from boots
one two to the body
over the top Under
from boots
oh left hook from boots
now folks from Karen nice
very very good oh left hook right hand
from Karen catches boots coming in Boots
had to shake his head
all right and then Karen goes right back
to the jab boots catches him with his
foot feet crossed oh right hand from
Karen nice turn to a hold
punch you in the face
punches of me grabs them
that's frustration at his finest people
nice jab oh right hand left hook right
hand oh shout out to your man Karen to
show you where he from he putting his
hood on the map boots is holding on his
Road his hand got caught in the Rope boy
I oughta turned off and knocked his
shoulders off
get off me
nice turn
give them that jab give him that jab oh
Bulls gave him the job right hand jab to
the belly right hand jab boots he ain't
dead man oh life [ __ ] oh
one two
who is this dude
bounce on a walk just bounce on him that
jab to the belly is something terrible
boy
something terrible is to stab with a
right hand he learned that from Floyd
looking crazy jab to the Face boots is
mad as hell
boots is mad as hell
come on man if you watching it you know
Karen out here doing his thing who's
just like what the hell is going on who
the hell is this mask man looking like
The Lone Ranger out there I'm calling
turn around knockdown
all right hey King love the gray beard
look brother no more shades though Flame
this is not IOP if you saw
the video I put out on a tweet who had
the shades on Shades be on the mall baby
I ain't got to read super chats tomorrow
this is my solo gig man this is my solo
act I gotta make sure I read those super
chats I can't read those on those tents
come on flame you know the truth
Eastern Europe is no joke those folks
toughest yeah man on God
these dudes out here boy they be out
there
they have wild animals in the street
they dogs ain't safe
they dogs ain't safe all right sorry
ain't no need to be sorry flame you know
I got love for you baby
all right here we go log that in the
building
boots try to end his career with that
right hand who called the 10th round
knockdown that was you will you got five
on it I got five on it tell me you got
five if you lose you gotta build a five
dollar Super Chat up there all right
well
because he ain't gonna get no knock down
in no tough round not the way Willie Pep
out here moving
Timmy pip
Willie is not trying to hear that right
there boots gonna have to kick him in
the stomach to get this knock down
he swung and he missed he hugged him so
get out of here take that package back I
ain't ordered that
this dude got the best knees in the
business boy
look at that
oh man boots is trying everything under
the sun to get this look at that
he looking like Allen Iverson he gave
him a crossover broke his knees
moves through a one two
doubled up on the jab and threw a right
hand and missed I told you boots has to
get an orthodox stance in order to have
a chance with this dude man and he's
keep fighting him in South Paul I'm
telling you it doesn't make any sense he
throws a one-two catches him
and then there you go the Mongoose spins
right back out again right back on the
back hill he can fight off his back foot
he has no problem with doing so boots is
stalking him but he's turning them
moving them left and right there you go
give me that jab he freezing boots look
look he froze him uh-huh
he's that kid on the schoolyard you
playing dodgeball when you just can't
hit him with that ball pulse
moving over Boop left hook boots
one two quart boots
boots want to put hands on them
oh he might you might get the knock down
on the other end will
happen over one two oh he punched him
very low to the gut very low boots was
disgusting with that low blow oh
turning them 39 seconds boots wanna land
something he punching them low that was
a very low shot to the Grind
he trying to hit that grunt
nah nah nah nah nah nah you ain't gonna
knock him down nope nope nope excuse me
[Laughter]
you trying to get him boots trying to
get him he got carried on the roof he
still can't get carried character ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one
sorry well I think you guys Super Chat
that five dollars
and said my bad King I think you know a
little bit more to me
you ain't knocking that dude down that
was a nice left hook if he knocked him
down from that left hook right there
nope sorry this guy is boom boom he's
trying his best man gotta respect him
he said I didn't say who either way sir
I was told to change us because you
party all night and Sunday you tired and
you are telling the truth
that sir is definitely for the record
books who said that
Makaya you definitely ain't lying you
know what
they're sitting right back here
ready for tomorrow
beautiful case right with a beautiful
case beautiful case beautiful case yes
yes that's what they sitting at ready
for the rocking tomorrow
all right round 11. well I'm still
waiting for that Super Chat
excuse me
oh nice chat nice job
oh
nice job
and they think we got tank right after
this
after these messages
we'll be right back
man
these are highly competitive fights
all of them
all right from all the undercards shout
out to Al Hayman and the PBC
uh for giving you your money's worth
Champions and challenges that are there
to give you a hundred and ten percent
of what you're asking for you know
nobody loses when everybody's out there
showing 110 and you know carrying out
here uh boxing boots
he landed a couple of shots right there
he spun off
you know he's Landing a couple of shots
on boots but boots is the stronger
fighter still keeps the strength all the
way through the pedigree is strong
you know boots is there
trying to catch him trying to push the
envelope of the fight
you know but Karen keeps moving nice jab
nice right hand nice jab from boots
right hand he Ducks under
spin excuse me
a nice Jab
right hand he got to grab them
he said man if you don't slow your
behind down excuse me
wet that palette
beautiful shot beautiful shot
there we go
boots throws a jab
he spends I mean this is the most that
boots is is trying to push Karen but
Karen again is throwing uh shots and
he's he's moving boots
to the referee when he clinches them
to make the ref break up the clinch you
see moves him holds them turns and
pushes them
make the referee break it up
oh and he tried he tried to hit boots
with that right hand he tried to do it
it's just he he doesn't have the power
in his shots to do so
you know
he doesn't have the power in the shots I
mean is is Karen out of his depth in his
fight fighting uh boots no boots is
showing his pedigree boots said he's
supposed to be the next up he's supposed
to be the next guy
um after Spence and Crawford he wants to
be the guy to fight Spence and Crawford
so you have to show the pedigree to be
that guy all right so this round he
separated himself uh from Karen
he landed the better shots he landed the
body shots he landed the the the head
shots nice Jabs nice right hands
um he did a lot in in establishing
um who should be winning this fight
right
Saturday morning cartoon commercials
after these messages if you ride back
yeah
sadly they don't get cartoons like that
no more
I'm a bill yes I'm only a bill and I'm
sitting on Capitol Hill
let me see what's going on here
oh God
all right so
last and final round
boots is jabbing
then the center of the Ring
oh he catches boots with a right hand
and a left hook and right hand
and he says come on he's there to be hit
they hit a fight
um
it was it was it was a nice good boxing
match and right now a fight broke out in
the 12th round
these dudes is going at it I think this
guy said well either he's gonna knock me
out or I'm gonna knock him out but I'm
gonna go try to go do something
so you know boots is hunting them and
Karen is hunting them right back boots
catches them with overhand right Karen
catches him with a right hand now
they're in the center of the ring in the
ring the referee is like break it up
break it up break it up
um and they're going right back at it uh
I I gotta respect both of them but this
is what happens when you put two boxes
in the ring with each other right so two
boxes is gonna box they're gonna box it
out and this is what I expected I
expected two boxes to box right so there
you go
nice Jab
nice right hand
pushing it
uh-huh
oh oh
what the hell is going on here they they
fighting it out
I told you they had such a lovely boxing
match now somebody told them that they
got a fight
and then they're in the middle of the
Ring fighting I mean yeah he's still
boxing yeah he's still giving angles but
this dude is out here really fighting
they're fighting
I mean as much as they they're gonna
fight they're fighting
and I gotta respect them I gotta respect
them go ahead boots go ahead oh nice
nice job Court Karen right in between
the shot oh but he's right there man
he's fighting man gotta respect this
dudes I gotta respect this card I hope
the the score cards aren't too
disrespectful I hope they gave him
enough rounds because I you know you
gotta respect the boxing Powers you know
Karen put it on the line
showed you uh that he can box with the
best and it was a good fight that was a
good fight
12 rounds 12 rounds of a hard 12 rounds
pause that was good that's my towel
thank you
definitely a good fight
it's a good fight good fight comrade
good fight that was your man that had on
the t-shirt in the in the in the uh this
the the Blazer
foreign
good fight good fight
good fight good fight good fight I'm not
gonna lie
with some good fight
so what we see here
all you guys ready for tank versus
Garcia
this is it right now this is what we
looking to get to
all right
so we're gonna get a chance to get a
hold of um
the winner
I hope I hope it's not a first round
knockout I hope he don't hit this boy
with the with the the bang and put him
to sleep I I want at least five six
rounds
I told you I give an eighth round
knockout eight ninth round knockout
I can see it going 12.
but eighth round ninth round
I I think that'll happen
a very good fight very good fight he put
up a hell of a counter himself
um I thought that uh his his he'll give
anybody a hell of a night a hell of a
night his boxing style is fantastic his
skills was on on Deck was good
oh
through favor of the winner
still undefeated
so boots boots won
he pushed the distance he pushed uh
ring General ship uh he control distance
he control Pace uh he pushed the fight
and um
it was it was it was worth it it was it
was it was worth it you know um young
Fighters need fights like this to see
different sides of the coin to see
different uh boxes and and punches so
so right now we're getting ready for the
main event
Hector might stink to join up after
filling the power maybe is he we're the
only fan shirt
yeah man yo who's paying yeah of course
he's wearing on that don't mean he got
the only fans page
that don't mean you you're gonna catch
Jerome boots tooting it up and booting
it up come on man
sponsors and sponsors
now now if he had a PornHub shirt on
then you could be like yo come on baby
you taking it too far
but come on now now there ain't nothing
wrong with the only fans come on
I mean sometimes you know only fans is
just only your fans got the content for
you why hey
well what you know about on defense
what's going on with you and only fans
did you know what's going on over there
[Laughter]
we'll we'll crazy well so now I only put
my um my RAID carries on only fans and
stop bothering me
[ __ ]
he said that man pimping somebody on
there
[Music]
yo don't put that indictment on that man
back don't get that man that jacket
he said boots is out there pimping only
hey yo come on man
that was good that was good that was
definitely dope
all right there we go there we go so
boots is in line for Earl Spence's
um
Whatchamacallit uh ibf title
you don't want nothing from that Savage
I'ma tell you right now you better stay
the hell away from Errol Spence
excuse me
Earl is not about none of that cap right
there
Earl to put hands on you for real
it ain't gonna be no slipping and
dipping and no super Mongoose no he
gonna try to kill you
he gonna try to put you in a slow motion
car wreck
you gotta ask your man
we ain't here no more from this dude all
right here we go
they praying in the background they
brought the priest in then brought uh
the Pope
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know you know spoke to all his
ancestors you know hit the WhatsApp
WhatsApp yo
dude this dude got on gym shorts
yo
oh this dude got Baltimore on his back
[ __ ] in the house
all the boys on the wire you don't know
why I feel be more in the house
boy is about to get turnt up right now
boy
oh somebody wrote it check their ass
can't cash
yo this kid is crazy like if you could
take Mike Tyson and squeeze him down
into lemon size to mini Mike Tyson bites
like Mike Tyson is a big Snicker ball
right so you know how you get the little
snicker bars on Halloween
that's tank Davis
yo oh my God could you imagine if he
grew up in the same time as Mike Tyson
Don King would have had a field there
because you know Don King would have
made sure that he got a hold of tank
right and you can have Mike Tyson and
tank on the same card
do you know what type of card that would
be that'd be knockout evening
knockout evening card
oh man
a lot of power a lot of power in those
hands so they're showing the betting
lines on what's going on here
sometimes I don't care shout out to my
boy Queen you know out there in Vegas
if I if I ever make bets I go through my
boy
Omar on the building
on my whistlers oh you know how I went
you know when Omar come through boy Omar
whistling through the hallways man just
put the bag on the stoop don't even let
them see you just put the bag in the
money on the stoop leave the cracks on
the floor I gotta get out of here oh my
outside
Omar from the wires in the building
Don King would have robbed all of them
dudes yeah yeah yeah you you can't use
the word you know come on man you gotta
put ninjas ninjas come on Makai come on
just put put put put ninjas put ninjas
ninjas work well you know ninjas ninjas
you know
I don't want nobody reporting you and
banning you you know just put ninjas
ninjas work well
y'all trying to figure out what I'm
doing I told you I wasn't Rick Ross told
you I ain't had no uh no eye to the left
or the right
you know Rick Ross got that wandering
baby eye
I don't I don't have the French Bulldog
no no
I don't know I think Makai heard the
truth the reason why I wear the shade
sir
he said hey you
it's cool it's cool
I keep it a buck don't worry about that
so we up to the last fight last fight of
the evening then I could turn uh fix my
my son's uh Wi-Fi for his laptop so he
can do his uh 20 minutes of homework
you know how you know when you could
have did your homework on Friday
but you want to hold it up until Sunday
I just look at him like keep on burning
the candle with both hands Papa
it'll catch up to you it'll catch up to
you
the main seals stand up
true dominicano
that's right demolo
I love
how much money he gonna make and how
much land he about to go back to the
Dominican Republic to buy
you gonna get back to the Dominican
Republic and this dude is gonna buy half
the other Island that's on the other
side when you look out
[Music]
daddy outside man they outside Taja game
Legos they outside boy they show up they
show up yo listen
tank ain't stupid
you fight Mexicans you fight Dominicans
you fight Puerto Ricans you fight any
kins
okay
okay
you fight any kid they show up they show
up and they show out they show support
man you don't play around
boy
that's right Stephen Jackson outside
everybody outside man it looked good man
let me see let me see let me see what's
on Twitter they slowing it up they're
slowing it up
no he said anything I never saw him
fight my God his speed yeah it was a
great fight shout out queeno
let me see what's going on on Twitter
wow
let me see let me see let me see
okay I can't listen to that because the
boy want to have parties out there all
right all right there goes Sean Porter
ah There Goes My Boy Gary Antoine
Russell
right that dude is nasty 16 and over 16
carry Kos he's nasty and it goes into uh
Gary Russell Jr that's right with this
cheryling on baby rock that he
he mad he had a whack coat on
that's right Derrick James is outside
scouting purposes only
boots can get this work as Arrow
Spencer's trainer there's uh Jamel
Charles trainer
scouting purposes only
I'm going for my flag
blocking OJ I respect you my wife is
going for her flag too
man you see so there you go I gotta I
gotta console her at the end of the
night
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a cousin cousin from my other
cousin from my other Auntie cousin from
the other cousin from the from the you
know you know how the island is
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know how the island is the island is
like that
yeah they all know each other from
around the corner from down the block
from up the street
[Music]
ten dollar Super Chat from necromances J
great fight combat talk with the King
here's another great year God bless 12
round win blocked in O.J King did you
know Z next gen 720 was trained by Ali
Bashar
oh for real that's cool
can he fight
I like to do celebrity boxing if y'all
want to set it up
hey you that dude King is a crazy boy
I I wouldn't know he don't follow me
I tell him to follow the kid
so
I'm not gonna make it a race thing
because it's not it's a paid thing you
know
they're both boxes they're both fighting
they both here
and um you got to respect to make it to
this level pay-per-view
headlining a card
you know if if
in front of in front of your family in
front of your team in front of
everybody
to to to become part of the elite of the
elite
that's what you strive for and
everything that you do if you're not
striving to be the best in your
profession
like like I used to have this rhyme
and Incognito notice
I'm the best in my profession when it's
time to perform I grabbed the mic and
check one too and I proceed to flow on
it's if if if you ain't the best
then what are you doing what are you
going for
so him headlining a card
on on a pay-per-view
he's he's he's here man
he's here he's here
all right so I hope everybody in the
Dominican Republic has pulled up a seat
I hope everybody in the Dominican
Republic is watching I hope everybody in
Baltimore is tuned in I hope the world
is watching because your boy's walking
out right now
and um he got only fans too
yo and he might be Pimping Pimping
hey let's go let's go let's go let's go
there we go
[Laughter]
this is dope right here here we go
crowd is packed that place is plaque
it's looks like it's sold out sold out
Arena
um so
tank can't look past this Garcia to get
to the next Garcia he got to take care
of one Garcia at a time so you got to go
from one Dominican to get to that one
Mexican so he has to do what he can
to win so oh my God this has to happen
and I Gotta Give Them respect this man
fought his way to this space he fought
his way here
so he he beat Colbert he beat
um uh what should we call it uh had his
name on the tip of my tongue post uh he
beat Gutierrez
to get here he he beat them to get here
so he earned his place this is what it's
about man
he said follow the kid cyan can throw I
don't know King David let's keep it up
let's keep it a buck if tank doesn't win
it's a gigantic upset hell yeah salute
we here at Baltimore city in the country
in the building wouldn't lose I'm proud
of my country you better be
better be
that we ain't gonna lie
we ain't gonna lie come on
let's go yeah you know she proud she out
here yeah that's that's the blood
flowing
let's see if she's still screaming by
the end of the night
and they say and they say no no
important
yeah okay
but if we win though
laughs
this is it right here man
you could have got that line up tighter
boy you don't you're on pay-per-view man
tighten up that lineup
let's go let's go let's go and now
introducing
the dude with the hardest fish
I said I'm I'm I'm a tank
God forbid
[Laughter]
oh who we got
he got two Migos
well stop being funny I'm not trying to
get canceled
I'm not trying to be canceled
nah that's Baltimore that's Baltimore in
the building he got he got a he got a
purse
oh man
that's a purse
By Any Other Name it's a purse
nah that's a purse
here we go here we go
I mean that's what you're supposed to do
right when you're in your town you're
supposed to
you're supposed to give a light to all
the artists and up and coming that's why
you're there that's that's what it's
supposed to be about right you're
supposed to give that ability you know
if when you're in that position
that you reach out to who's the hottest
in your town right there and you give
them light to give them that push to
give them that that goal
I mean because the world is going to be
watching this right so that that's what
you do that's what you're supposed to do
that's what eye Lords do we look and we
see Yo who who's who's what's what's
moving what's shaking and let's go let's
lift everybody up because remember oh oh
oh
oh oh here we go
fur coat gang in the building
fur coat gang in the building
that's what we talking about fur coat
gang in the building
don't get mad don't get mad just put
that he got a full length fur too fur
coat gang in the building
let's go for a coat full length
there you go
tank look like you're having a good time
boy
I don't know it looked focused and he
looked hydrated because he looked
dehydrated at the weigh-in so he looked
hydrated now
he looked like he ready for action boy
he looked like he Ready for War shout
out to stiff and J Paul's all right it's
chilly out here in Maryland on God
oh God look at that oh that's not full
length but that that's oh that's that's
the length I got that's the length I got
there you go
there you go there you go
yeah that white guy like get that fur
off my chest mind your business
[Laughter]
even the cop popping his neck
that's that Philly bounce that brother
Baltimore bounce that love that swag he
got police tag on him hey yo
it came in there
he came in there chalking him out
oh my God
he brought crime scene tape
he fitting to put him in a body bag hey
yo that is the most disrespectful thing
I have ever seen in my life he brought
crime scene tape in the ring
choke him out
chalk him out he brought Christ he taken
the ring
your man's a pure Savage
I've never seen nothing like that in my
life
oh God that was dope
now when you lock down the block you put
that crime scene tape hey can't come
through here
it's a body in the trunk what you gonna
do
oh man
he 31 years old a little up there a
little long in the toe Papa
five eight five five got a little three
on them you got a little two inches on
that reach oh
[Music]
tank like to get up under them tall
dudes ah like to get up under them ribs
like to fold them up and bring them down
like ham sandwich type
land no shots boy get terrible for you
up in them rings
shout out to me again screen record
it'll be my day
oh that's what's up
let's go let's go
here we go
sound like somebody needs rattling
that boy look comfortable as hell up in
that ring always
looking bad little kid boy he that bad
little kid
his chest look weak
he got that chest that you smacked like
man get your chest right man get your
chest right poke out your chest man
your man just nipples him back
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
my God his chest ain't fully developed
yeah yeah with the baby chest you have
some baby chest in there
that's right Nori classic track is a
body in the trunk so what we gonna do
sooner or later
I was listening to that not too long ago
here we go here we go
tank let's get it baby
shout out to tank let's get it baby
oh
Washington D.C the murder capital of the
world
oh shout out to Baby chess
thank you
yo it looked like his head don't belong
to his body
ain't got jokes for real
yo you look like a bobble head like
you know the joint that you put on your
dashboard and his head darker than his
chest why your face darker than your
chest no
let's get it oh man
make me a Believer bro
make me a believer
that's right
they all sized on the outside he said
that's my son
that's my son
I love him
please please Papi don't die
he's 27-0 with 25 Knockouts the beat
down is fitting the commence son
shout out to the bad man
yup
shout out to the bad man look at the
dude behind them
he got shades on in the night time
look at the dude behind him but it's
fitting to be horrible
he said all that bobble head action
it'll block the New Jersey my
condolences
yeah they brought his family front row
seats son right that's right witness
this here we go they both look like the
same height it's fitting to be hard
rubbo
let's get it oh my God he looked bigger
than him
oh my god
let's go
laughing too much I'm sorry man y'all
gotta shut me up
gotta show me something gotta show me
something special look at that
foreign
let's go
let's go he's still he still earned his
right to be here wow Wow Let's Go
he earned his right to be here he earned
it
here we go
from the best stair down to the round
one
so right now they're in the center of
the Ring
hmm
excuse me
all right
so you gotta
Hector jabbing
tank High guard
nice quick jab from tank
like to throw the Jab
nice job
foreign
he uses the elbow technique
and a flick jab with the right stand
home so he's using uh
sort of like a Philly show
and with a dip down
uh tank is familiar with the Philly show
technique because remember he uh trained
under the greatest fully shell technique
uh and uh Floyd
so
they're right in the center of the Ring
nothing really happening
um
I see it throwing out Jabs
tank throwing out Jabs
so
they dip down
so knowing that both of them are you
know southpaws it doesn't matter they
both cancel each other out so it's like
nobody has the advantage as far as
stance go
you know
so it just boils down to you know Style
so what what I don't like what Garcia
does is he locks his legs and he has a
white stance right so actually he's
making himself uh shorter than he needs
to make himself uh when it comes to tank
but I guess you want to have a solid
foundation uh for when tank rushes in so
you can meet his force with Force so
it's pretty much probably going to be a
left hook or a right hand underneath
that he's trying to land like that uh
that left hook right there that he he
tried to throw over the top
all right so
a right job from uh tank
so and uh Garcia is not pushing any
uh distance that was probably the
quickest round
in boxing
and went by very very quickly nothing
happened really first round
nothing at all um they still did
posturing with each other Idol jabs back
and forth uh nothing really nothing
happened I guess feeling each other out
getting the nervous Kinks out the way
but nothing nothing too spectacular
yeah tank does look way bigger than them
it's a Dominican let's put on the
Dominican Spirit Bomb
[Laughter]
I feel you Thomas
oh man
it's um this is this is
ah
this is this is funny this is funny
because he's not pushing the fight and
he's not
um
really giving up too much ground
as far as Garcia is
and take tank is uh he wants to get a
sweat so he wants to put in probably at
least four rounds and you know how it
goes he gets the four rounds and but
what I don't like what Garcia is doing
is he's not giving tank any movement
he's standing very stationary right in
front of tank and you know tank is
rotating around him so the Trap tanks
likes to set is he likes to have the
opponent over commit with a jab or right
hand and he counters off of these shots
and he works his way in so right now he
he wants he wants Garcia to go to the
body tank throws a jab To The Head And
if tank can start Landing Jabs then he
would follow those up with strong left
hands which is what he's trying to do
right now
so he's stepping and jabbing in right
and he Jabs up
and he he's trying to get uh Garcia to
step out of frame if he can get Garcia
to step out of frame then he can land
the left hand uh Garcia throws a jab
over his Jab
um no
um left hands from Garcia as of yet
everything is off the jab so it's a jab
left hook I mean Jeff right hook
jab remember they both southports so
it's a jab right hook jab right hand you
know jab jab jab all of it is just Jabs
all right right now
um he's touching the guard of
of tank and he tried to throw a left
short left inside
very very very disciplined first and
second round he went to Tank's body
which was very low
huh
nothing too much right now
and that ring is gigantic I mean uh for
these uh smaller Fighters
a nice one-two from Garcia and tank is
closing distance now so so tank is
walking him back in closing distance
remember we just saw a closing distance
without jabbing uh from Villa right
and remember how detrimental I said that
was and and that was from a fighter that
I didn't know
so Garcia throws a one too and he goes
right back he's trying to you know
loosens tank uh hands bring tank hands
down for to the body tank is trying to
get him up against the ropes to land
that overhandle uh left that he likes to
throw
so he's jabbing
and he's putting immense pressure on
Garcia
and he's trying to land that overhand he
lands the overhand and the round is over
like he said he'll catch him just give
him some time and it's probably going to
happen
he said tank is a small cat lift up the
Dominican hands
y'all are ridiculous
I feel you man
I feel you man
all right so they're back in the corner
these rounds is is breezing by you know
because I guess it's because it's not
too much being done you know so these
these rounds are breezing by
tank looks interested
he's listening
talking to his corner and he he he he's
he's a very uh attentive dude like he
listens to his coin he listens to what
they tell him
very very attentive when it comes to
listening to his trainer that's a good
bond that they have
all right so they're back in the center
of the Ring
nice jab so all right so tank is
starting to faint and he starts to close
this and so he's starting to put his his
uh right foot inside the center of
Garcia's right foot and he's trying to
to uh gain dominance right Garcia's
keeping him back with the jab right hand
Jabs
trying to push tank back tank is trying
to catch in Pitch so what tank wants to
do is catch him with his jab hand down
and throw a overhand left excuse me
to catch him off of God he tries right
there and he there he goes so he wants
to get close enough to Garcia to land a
couple of uh shots that can hurt like
that shot right there he tries to catch
him overhand and Garcia tries to come
right back with his shot in the center
of the Ring oh nice right hand from uh
Garcia he caught tank flush
nice good hand I mean left hand from
Garcia Court tank fresh
tank shake his head we all know what
that means so he tries to throw another
right hand from tank tank catching some
with a sharp Jab
back to right hands
all right
tank goes to the body jab he's trying to
get Garcia to the ropes Garcia is being
very smart by turning and tank is
stalking like Julius sees a Chavez Style
with the feet
and moving them over Garcia is rotating
and throwing tank throws over Garcia
freezes in the center to the ring
and tank is not throwing full power so I
hope Garcia doesn't think that he can
take Tank's power
because it's very sharp one minute left
in round number three overhand left left
hook from Garcia
tank stands there rolls with the shots
the shots doesn't hit Garcia is being
stalked tank is walking down on him and
they both freeze right there I think
that's that's a bad idea I think more
movement is necessary tank throws a
right hand
Garcia goes right back in tank lunges
with uh left
and a nice cover-up by Tank
and he's portioning the distance on
Garcia
he's trying to get close and he's one
scarcity to commit to that hand he wants
Garcia to throw the left hand
because he is not throwing the left hand
he's holding the left hand at bait and
that's what tank wants him to do is
throw the left hand while he's stalking
him he's pushing him up against the
ropes and the round is over
again it's a mirror of the first two
rounds
tank stalking Garcia's trying to keep
him at Bay with drunk throwing the the
jab right hand
and uh
it's it's pretty good he goes over his
tank in the the back of the head
really not too much stuff he misses
he misses he misses all his shots
um
Garcia's throwing shots but he's not
throwing the shots that I think he wants
to throw
it at the proper time
right so it's not like
um
it's not trying to lead he's not trying
to take the lead yet tank is still
leading but tank is still leading by
putting pressure without putting power
behind the pressure so
we have round number four remember all
fights heat up after round number five
six here we go
there we go so you know
um Garcia is throwing a jab to keep tank
back and
take throws his Jab
it has to be a forceful job and um
Garcia is not throwing forceful jobs
he's throwing very light Jabs at Garcia
at uh tank
and go
he's pushing
nice Jab
goes right back at it nice job
and tank swoops on
and put some on a defensive posture
all right
go okay and here goes tank trying to
land some of those shots and Garcia's
trying to defend and keep him off and he
goes to the body of tank but tank is
right there trying to throw the right
hand nice left hook from uh Garcia tank
throws the left hook right hand Garcia
throws the right hand to keep tank off
of him
nice jab from Garcia
they both in the center to the ring and
tank is closing the distance
it feels like uh one of those cartoons
when an anvil was about to drop out the
window
so
there goes the right the the left hand
and it goes the left hand
there goes the left hand right hand from
tank take trying to land this left hook
right hand
and he's stalking and Garcia lands the
left hook on Garcia's chin Garcia backs
up his head doesn't look too sharp
all right tank comes back Garcia looks
clean now
right hand from Garth from tank tank is
trying to land that overhand left
Garcia's taking too many shots it does
nothing look good for him if he
continues to take these shots right here
Garcia leg doesn't look right tank looks
like he's pushing Garcia throws the one
two three Garcia takes it Garcia throws
the one two tank throws it
Garcia is pushing he's trying he's
trying to walk tank in and this is where
the mistake happens this is what tank
wants you to do push the dag on lead and
don't let Tank lead
and here you go
this is a nice fight this is what we're
looking for tank established a couple of
things in that round that he can touch
Garcia and Garcia establish something
too that he would fight back
all I do is watch tank back foot he's
always got the toe ready to Pivot
and off the pivot see that was a nice
digging shot to the body and he catches
tank with a nice uh left hook to the
face
so
tank is always in Runners mode right
Runners mode is the off the pivot foot
nice punch with the shoulder underneath
that Garcia couldn't counter tank didn't
hit him flush he hit him enough to back
Garcia up and Garcia you know realize
tank could punch something but tank
didn't put anything full under it yet
all right so all right
he's very coherent tank is very coherent
in between rounds he sees and he's
talking with his corner I think that
means a lot
here we go so we got round five right so
we all know if anybody's in the house
the king understands that the fight
starts in round number five
everybody knows round number five is the
indicator of how the fight should start
to heat up and go to right
but this card has been like round six
this card it seems like everybody
realizes somebody's check goes on hold
starting round six so
here we go
here we go
that tank all right so tank is
establishing long punches here we go
there we go
the tank is jabbing his way in
he's on the ready
all right here we go
what's up
Garcia is ready to throw
um tank is right there wanting him to
commit tank is land in the jab you don't
want tank Landing Jabs Garcia's back is
close to the ropes
um
all right Garcia's pivot right back to
the center to the ring he throws a 1-2
but tank isn't there
is a nice one too
right nice one too from Garcia
he's throwing punches perfectly
and both of them is standing in the
middle of the Ring freezing looking at
each other
nothing's being thrown right now
all right take is trying to catch them
all off guard
Garcia
is throwing Jabs to the body he tries to
go over the top with the left hand
tank blocks it tanks is in the middle
he's trying to land the one two up close
Garcia will have to land if he's going
to land and he's gonna have to land over
the top
tank is coming in lands the right hand
and a left hook in close
tank Jabs to the body
and he's setting up the left
and keep setting up the straight left
he wants to dig the right hand under the
bottom
Garcia back is against the Rope
and tank throws it over the top Garcia
shoulder pump some
Garcia throws a 1-2 tank rolls it
20 seconds left in round number five
Garcia punches is too slow
yeah
tank is throwing sharp shots to go sharp
I see a body overhand right one two from
tank
and he wants Garcia to take the league
Garcia doesn't round is over
so
now that we see what tank is trying to
do and what Garcia isn't allowing him to
do see tank wants to get Garcia up
against the ropes but Garcia is smart
enough to know and he's tank is landing
some strong shots Garcia is following up
with every strong shot that tank lands
he's following up with a shot so he's
trying to keep tank from getting him to
his back to the ropes so he's fighting
his way off the ropes instead of
pivoting left or right what he's doing
his fighting tank back right so tank a
land is shot or tank a throw a shot and
he'll he'll throw his shot so it's like
rock paper scissors
trying to out uh out guess what tank is
going to throw
footwork is amazing definitely
footwork is absolutely amazing
oh
what is it what is it with this six
round the sixth round Garcia came out
and just threw a left hook somebody is
in the corner yelling out the check
Clyde back
somebody's doing something like yo the
money's in the bank get busy I don't
know what they're saying because
everybody looked different in this sixth
round this whole night
the sixth round has been the babadook
for all his rounds let's go
here we go
there we go
tank is leaning
oh nice nice left hook they both
exchange uh left hook nice jab core tank
off balance tank switched his feet oh
tank went off the docks
tank went Orthodox okay and he went back
South Park
that was crazy
Garcia's throwing one two threes
all right here we go so now we have the
winging we have them at the way and the
same thing at the weigh-in that we saw
with tank pushed them off and then he
showed him Philly shell right so he
showed him the wing right this is it
right here so now we're gonna see the
push off hook right
there we go so Garcia is going to the
body tank is going to the head you're
gonna see who wins on that all right
Garcia tank is throwing punches to land
now
Garcia is jabbing how you win a fight is
you win with a jab right nice right hand
from uh tank left hook from tank very
strong left hooks on the inside
nice job from tank tank is pushing them
back trying to get them set them up for
this for this uh this left hook he's
trying to get him a position for the
left hook and Garcia is turning nice
left hook from tank Garcia throws a
double jab and goes right to tank body
um
nice nice from Garcia Garcia throws a
nice left hand in close
all right tank throws a one two and he
goes right back to Tank's body he might
find Tank's weakness by going to Tank's
body nice body shots from uh Garcia
Garcia is uh earning some respective
nice jab tank goes right to Garcia's
body
I guess sometimes you got to show the
the power
um
I think maybe the head might not be the
key nice uh right hand from tank a nice
left hook from tank Garcia goes right
back to the jab round is over best round
of the fight I blocked an OJ two dollar
super Jack 12 round King Garcia
shout out to you putting that in the
Super Chat so I can talk to you tomorrow
in the morning
so they said uh tank how you feeling
said I feel good
so what I want you to do is I want you
to slide up under his Ribs Right
and I want you to punch Eve out of them
[Laughter]
I want you to punch a rib out of them
oh boy
let's get it
this is what I'm talking about this is
what we came to see we came to see good
fights right so round six is definitely
what it's supposed to be
he said it's in color blocking a j
I think you might got the wrong Garcia
there we go here we go
oh nice shoulder bump nice shoulder hey
man that's from the Philly shell I told
you he knows the elbow the Philly shell
is the elbow all right right hand hooked
to the body
right hand all right so right now Garcia
is standing his ground right he's he
puts his foot in the ground and he uses
his jab to control distance
so tank has to get past the jab right so
Garcia and tank right now
is going in
all right so tank is pairing inside
trying to get inside
all right Garcia keeps hooking a tank to
the body
all right all right here we go Garcia's
jabbing and he's going right to Tank's
body
tank is coming in tank goes right to
Garcia's body nice hook he's going to
the left to the Head nice jab from tank
Garcia goes right back to tank body
right they're both Landing shots nice
left hook from uh Garcia Garcia lands a
nice left hook on Tank's chin he's
walking tank down he's coming in all
right he catches tank with a nice punch
all right tank looks over to his corner
all right so they're back in the center
he's trying to get Garcia to commit to a
shot and Garcia is keeping his hands
close
all right he understands if he gonna win
just win by uh 12 rounds it doesn't
matter if you win by anything else nice
job from Garcia he's trying to control
distance tank is cutting the ring and
there you go with the overhand left all
right there you go with the underhand
right left from tank uh huh all right
Garcia is Landon Garcia's fighting back
tank is throwing shots Garcia is
fighting back with the jab left hook
Garcia is backing up he doesn't give
tank the back ropes like tank wants
tank does his best work off the ropes
and Garcia is narrowly missing uh
getting hit by the overhand left from
tank
it won't be the overhand left from tank
actually
it'll probably be uh uppercut or a hook
to the body
but it's not going to be to the Head
Garcia shows that he has a good chin
from what I've noticing
all right so
round number seven is in the books
make some BBQ EU tips and he's doing
good it's like it's like we're really
there thank you flame I appreciate it
very good stuff here
the wife said I'm eating Mango tomorrow
we gotta get more Dominicans fighting I
like mango
there we go nice job
good he's telling him to stay close I
think that's the wrong uh
I think Felix told him the wrong thing
I think Felix told him the wrong thing I
think you need to keep tank at a
distance I don't think you need to take
to let Tank close any distance at all so
don't keep anything tight keep them at a
distance
um but he told him to keep it tight so
that means he's going to shorten up his
punches and um if he allows the tank to
get him up against any form of ropes
which will meet detrimental
right there
oh nice uppercut from Garcia nice jab
there we go so all right so they told
him to close distance right hand from
Garcia left hook from Garcia right hand
from tank left hook from tank
trying to land the overhand right Garcia
is throwing a 1-2 uppercut from Garcia
it don't matter
that's their business
he fighting keep fighting
time out wow
timeout
wow
there's always something stupid
it's always something stupid
and the fight is stopped right now
because something went on I think it has
something to do with Sean Porter
oh Sean Porter he couldn't fight he said
you mean I still got it
[Laughter]
nah she ain't think it was Ryan Garcia
fighting tonight
man she know the difference of King Rob
and block the no uh uh uh uh Garcia she
she know she Ryan Garcia is Mexican so
she knows the difference she's she's
going with a country man remember she's
Dominican she's going to go with a
country man she knows I put her up on
game I let her know who Hector Garcia
was
I told you I told you who it was I told
who I said it was
who did I said it was I said it was Sean
Porter who did I say it was right
who did I say was you got to go
who did I say it was
who did I say I said it was what it was
I know gay
all right run up on them and knock them
out
yeah
get him when he's not looking
boy as soon as he turned his head I'd
have pitched his shoulders right off his
body
Garcia is fighting with a new vigor
so they took my cousin out
there you go here we go
nice one too
here we go Garcia Miss he's over
committing now
uh-huh
tank is trying he's staying close to
tank there you go that's how you're
supposed to fight it that's how you're
supposed to fight are you supposed to
fight it close come on let him get close
nice to the body oh nice overhand left
from tank
tank face is a little touched up that
jab has done some things to him
Garcia jab is very nice he has a very
educated jab Tank's left hook is very
good very good right hand he's Bing
bopping him but I'm not gonna lie Garcia
jab is very very educated when I say
it's an educated job I mean an educated
job understands where it needs to go
very decent Jab
uh-huh there you go
Garcia is throwing one twos he's
standing in his ground he's making tank
fight him so tank has to set his feet
properly nice uppercut from tank nice
right hand from tank tank is placing
shots right now Garcia's fighting back
but this is the part where his Corner
told him to keep it tight so let's see
if he can keep it tight right boom left
hook from tank left hook right hand from
tank Garcia throws left hook right hand
because I see it throws right hands tank
throws left and right under the body
right hand over the top oh and sleepy
time for Bonzo let's get the block the
nose off of you mean I got to sleep
let's get it
let's go
one more round one more round hey one
more round let's get it now yo he hit
him over the top of his head he said hit
him in the soft spot you know when
babies got a soft spot at the top he hit
him he said DOMA
[Laughter]
you know with the cocoa
[Music]
I can't feel my legs
[Laughter]
what the hell was that um
don't taste good what you what you got
your gloves
he said hi
wait a second wait a second that's what
his body said time out man
you hit you hitting different different
shut up you said shut up and get in the
corner
relax poppy
fight is over it's Corner said nah
you know when you take a picture you
take a picture in your mind
he said um
he said meter no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no he said that guy
that guy right there Diablo no no more
no more
please please please stop the fight that
was a setup that fight yeah it was a
setup set him up to get knocked out baby
don't let them clown you tomorrow please
I can't deal it could dude I can't I
can't deal with it don't let them do you
this bad just take your loss take your
loss take your loss like Garcia
he said no Moss he said no Moss I I do
not want any more he said who is that
wait a second wait a second he said wait
a second hold a second that's tank Davis
he said oh that's tank Davis that's the
guy on fight I'm out of here
stop the fight
[Laughter]
yo his body ain't right son I told you
he hit him in a soft spot
he said not tonight on God and me not
this evening he said nah my grandma
watching she ain't watching me get
knocked out turn this off
he said we did six my check cleared
I'm good
[Laughter]
Man this ain't Gotham City I ain't
Batman I ain't got to save nobody
said not the day Satan you will not take
it you will not I had a lot of people
fly in I got to go to the club later
he said Tego Calderon is the DJI
oh
we all together we all together man we
all together we all won Yo a modern
ghetto he's gonna be there yeah he's
gonna be yeah he gonna play if that's
make you feel better
oh my God
she hurts I told her I told he he
fitting to go night night son he said
you are not disrespecting me on TV not
with my fam I flew my family in you are
not knocking me out
I will not be on your highlight real yo
I saw the punch
[Laughter]
on God and Mim
and with that folks it concludes another
high entertaining first fight of 2023.
combat talk with the King I'm Gonna
Leave y'all with that outro that is my
intro
and I want you guys to watch us with
iron Lord's podcast tomorrow I want to
thank everybody that showed up everybody
that super chatted everybody that
supported everybody that retweeted
everybody that told their friends thank
you so much it means everything to me
more than you know trust me it means
everything to me and I'm Gonna Leave
y'all with this outro that is the intro
God bless
[Music]
as tonight
presented boxing after Dark
fights out can't hit a thing when it
lights off can't talk heavy with a light
job
can't hear the thing when your lights
off can't talk hit me with a light Joe
might win might lose or my draw
ing
hate to send love but it come back so if
you really want it in the ring God don't
send the contract off knock his contacts
out
ain't no competition in the ring of
Cypher cause I'm spitting phenomenal
swinging fire talking
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
sandwich
even got his winning only homie Kevin
you a phony homie now you owe me action
have him singing Tony Tony Toni Braxton
and they all wanna talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for an instant
mama got hands doing bread for the
tension imma leave them red you can
dance to Redemption
[ __ ]
[Music]